president joe biden is going to brief
the country on the state of our union
and today i'm going to brief you about
the state of the david pakman show it's
it's been an incredible year um the
second year of the covet pandemic
the first year of joe biden's presidency
economic uncertainty vaccines inflation
other calamities 2021 was an incredibly
strong year from the standpoint of the
show
and i can report to you that the state
of the david pakman show is very very
strong some say the best that we've seen
um in 2021 we added more than 200 000
youtube subscribers not the most we've
ever added in a year but the most we've
ever added in a non-election year
and that is now putting us within
striking distance of 1.5
million youtube subscribers our friends
over at the young turks have been really
the standard bearers or left wing
youtube channels for a very long time
and i can report to you with total peace
and love that in the last few months the
david pakman show youtube channel is
receiving more daily views than the
young turks main channel friendly
competition their network is way bigger
than ours we love everybody over there
but just a reminder with a small team
you can do some pretty amazing things
in terms of the audio podcast monthly
downloads are now at their historic peak
our previous peak was that crazy period
between the november 2020 election and
the trump riots that was our high water
mark we are at a new high water mark now
with the audio podcast the most
downloads a month in the history of the
show
we've got new platforms quickly growing
nearly a hundred thousand followers on
instagram nearly a hundred thousand
followers on tick tock we've launched
youtube shorts content instagram reels
content
2021 also saw the return of the david
pakman show town hall events hugely
popular with our core audience
but
the year was not without some major
challenges
we received the 90-day monetization ban
from facebook after our content was
wrongly flagged for spreading covered
disinformation something i would never
do but it was a big hit to our revenue
thanks to the hard work of nearly a
dozen facebook employees who are in our
audience we were able to get that
monetization ban reversed in under a
month but it's a stark reminder of how
precarious these revenue sources are
more recently we got a 24-hour ban and a
community guidelines strike on tick tock
due to another false positive in a
segment where we criticized right wing
actor kevin sorbo and his opinion about
health care we were banned for 24 hours
and now one strike closer
to a permanent ban from tick tock and of
course we were targeted by right-wing
conspiracy theorist alex jones who
launched a brutal attack on my
appearance on my eyes on my face
uh discharged a number of salvos against
our bonus show
so we are up against some major
obstacles
and attempting to move uh towards a sort
of more media literate critically
thinking society donald trump continues
to deliver these erratic febrile screeds
on a regular basis his followers love it
fox news continues to spread
disinformation sometimes spending 24
even 48 hours talking about
hillary clinton must soon be going to
prison given all the crimes she
supposedly committed just boogeymen
boogeymen of critical race theory
cancellations dr seuss it's pervading
right-wing media and their followers
fall for it
a seemingly on speed don jr regularly
inciting the most bottom dwelling pond
scum of the political right in these
apoplectic froths
over misunderstandings and distortions
and that's not going to stop
sadly
and it is sad
even some on the left fall for the
disinformation many so-called leftists
wildly attacking me for being a supposed
imperialist bastard despite my constant
refrains that i am against american
intervention abroad in almost all cases
the facts do not matter to too many
people
but
we will not give up and we will continue
to persevere because i see the good
in the independent media audience i see
it in that 15 year old canadian kid who
recently called in inspired so many of
you
with his wit and his intelligence and
his curiosity i see it in the people
emailing me 20 30 40 times every day
even though their emails have been
filtered into the trash for months
they're still enthusiastically emailing
me
i see it even in the right wing troll
callers who we know
are calling constantly because they see
us having an impact that's why they
won't stop leaving me voicemails they're
worried
that we're talking sense and that people
are understanding it
that's the david pakman show i know
and that's why i can confidently tell
you today the state of the union no the
state of the show
is as strong as ever and it makes me
hopeful about the future of independent
media thank you
and god bless
the united fish
wow what a speech there folks letting
everybody know the latest in terms of
the
state of the david pakman show welcome
welcome come on in i am glad to have you
here we are uh just moments away really
somewhere between a few minutes and
seven hours away from joe biden's state
of the union speech it'll probably be at
nine eastern but it could be anywhere in
that range and it will subsequently be
followed by the republican response to
the state of the union address and that
is expected to be
remarkably remarkably weaponized and so
we have all of the feeds here for you
i do want to mention we are also
very closely watching what's happening
in ukraine
where
you could quite literally have massive
dumps of bombs and that's not a joke
as joe biden is speaking tonight
as has been happening around this time
every night now it is
uh what is it 309 a.m in ukraine
sometime in the next 90 minutes
potentially significant escalation uh so
we're gonna be watching all of it and i
am so glad to have everybody here with
us today
um we i do want to say i hope that this
is not
i hope this doesn't bode poorly for us
but we've never had to ban as many
people as we banned today before
starting like an hour ago
i looked through the chat on youtube
and it was toxic gutter trash and i
think we banned 11 people
before we were even streaming and that's
never happened before
and that does not bode particularly well
but maybe we can turn it around i don't
know i don't know what to tell you guys
but it was very very ugly what was uh
what was going on there um in the
meantime a bunch of different huge
stories in a moment i'm going to tell
you uh what
i'm hoping to hear or what i'm expecting
to hear from joe biden there are a bunch
of different breaking stories including
that the belarusian president
appeared to share a map suggesting
russia plans to invade moldova next and
we're going to look at this in detail on
tomorrow's show but you know when when
when the when the intelligence started
to suggest
putin's ambitions may be bigger than
ukraine
uh
and we said it's probably true
um
some people said no no no no there's no
way well it appears that it may well be
the case so we're going to be
covering that tomorrow and that's the
latest news
if you want to play joe biden's state of
the union bingo with us today it is
available to you you can generate a
custom bingo board at davidpakman.com
bingo
i will be playing i will be playing
today and i i invite you to play along
with me i think it would be a really
really great thing um we'll go through
the different boxes in a little bit but
davidpakman.com
bingo is the place to check that out uh
russian forces escalating attacks on
ukraine's civilian areas one of the
stories that's been told and it really
is just a story really more of a fantasy
is that only
uh military targets only military
targets have been hit by russia and that
does not appear to be the case at all
with endless evidence to contradict it
so that is the latest out of russia
um and uh it's all looking very very bad
to be honest um we talked yesterday and
today on the podcast i hope you're
signed up to the podcast about this the
ukrainian ambassador to the united
nations saying listen if putin's
determined to just destroy everything he
could just kill himself he doesn't need
to
destroy all these other people and
places he could just take his own life
and that's it
and um
many people saying i'm not for suicide
but that is uh that is probably the best
thing putin could do at this point in
time
let me start welcoming people in and
saying hello brian via super chat says
thank you for the great coverage and
insights david great to have you here
brian
zeff says david
sir
sir sure
how strongly do you think this address
will be pretty strongly
sarah says i seem to recall you were
going to do a show with matt dillahunty
whatever happened to that was that was
like i feel like it was about a year ago
it got cancelled because i had a
conflict and it just never got
rescheduled
um larry says hello david my fellow
pac-maniacs hope everyone is doing well
glad bless yes exactly and god bless
the united states right
right absolutely and completely correct
there okay let me thank great people who
are here having a party uh the following
people have just signed up via twitch
and twitch prime and i can't tell you
how much i love it whoa already a ton of
people
jay tanegawa pizza man john the elder
dragon slingblade gasoline
john the elder dragon with a gift i see
in
jack chrissy oswin and andrew dale
drone foddage
fino jen here badness j.p de beast
deeper shades of house fatsy frank milk
mellow melly
sam the sleazebag wanson man kicks and
ryan rincon oh my god we are already all
the way up to 23
and i haven't even played any voicemails
from whitney yet
uh
shocking truly shocking
um david can we get a ban men and we
will ban men one thing okay so what do i
expect to hear tonight from joe biden
let's go into that i don't expect joe
biden to advocate for banning men i
don't expect joe biden to talk about
maxell cohn mexico right here's what i
expect number one
i do expect joe biden to sort of claim
victory over the virus i do
um there have been over the last 24 to
48 hours
a number oh issues president biden will
address okay these are general so in
terms of the tone i do think he's going
to sort of claim victory on the virus
and say a lot of people can stop wearing
masks the cdc has passed uh or not
passed
release new guidelines to that end i
think we're going to see that i think we
are going to see significant foreign
policy focus because of what's going on
in ukraine and russia i do believe that
joe biden is going to start to position
the case for electing democrats in
november and i don't know how
successfully he will do it i'm curious
to see that uh i believe joe biden
will address inflation
um i am uh
thinking joe biden will propose
some major new policy initiative he
needs a policy success
um and then beyond that i think there's
going to be a lot of
kind of like pr focus stuff i believe
that there is
it's the the wife of some prominent
ukrainian person i guess is going to be
up in the gallery
um with jill biden
and um so i think there's going to be a
lot of that i think it's going to be
heavy on rhetoric i would guess it goes
about 70 minutes
roughly is my prediction i'm curious to
hear from others what you expect as far
as that goes
chaka seki says mike pillow is going to
rebuild the russian economy with his
proposed pillow strika hey by the way
why isn't pillow donating pillows to
ukraine i mean quite frankly you know
he's donating them to anyone
other than than in you it's crazy
kevin says david i cannot imagine
another predator to watch the state of
the union with that is a freaking
predator right there brian says i
understand many countries providing
weaponry to ukraine but is there any
substitute for countries providing
troops
there really isn't and i'm not
advocating for that i'm just saying
there really isn't a substitute for that
joshua says many news outlets talk about
the importance of giving putin an out to
end conflict what do you think that
looks like yeah i mean listen i i don't
we talked about this on the bonus show
today i don't particularly think this is
a likely outcome of negotiations
but if there were to be negotiations
that putin would accept
my guess is it would look something like
putin leaves everywhere other than
donetsk luhansk in crimea
he's allowed to keep them
he
signs off on he's not
in principle opposed to ukraine joining
nato
but it's it's like it's really unlikely
to it's really uh it seems unlikely that
ukraine would accept it and it seems
unlikely russia would accept it but when
you think about what are the main points
that you would imagine would come up
they are those but it seems completely
implausible that it's actually going to
be accepted so
i don't know
i don't know
let's see what else we've got will i
cover the republican response i probably
will i probably will it depends how the
stream is going but i probably will if
it's not past my bedtime david sir i
turned my husband into a pac fan we're
watching together he even got his own
membership thank you for all you do no
thank you
why doesn't biden announce he's
legalizing weed it's unclear he can
legally do it there's disagreement as to
whether he can
let me thank some other great people
brian marks just signed up on my website
daritha villatoro is a new member and
logan rutledge has just signed up new
members 24 25 and 26 also thanks over on
twitch to k mcgregor short brief napa
skip dog final heaven paco taco as well
um putting us in a really strong
position at 31. if you're just joining
us we're about to 40 minutes from the
state of the union we do have biden
bingo
let's review what our boxes are on biden
bingo david davidpakman.com
bingo you can generate your own bingo
board i expect to crush all of you
in bingo
okay let's go through the boxes one
biden tells one of those dad used to say
stories he often will tell those stories
two biden uses the term folks to address
people
biden whispers into the microphone as
some of you know he will sometimes do
that
for example uh mentioning uh zelensky i
think it's very likely he will mention
zolensky we see someone in the audience
sleeping
we see someone in the audience sleeping
discussion of gas prices likely i think
likely
uh biden mispronounces something listen
trump would do it sometimes biden does
it as well not not you know the biggest
deal mexico
a biden capping or punctuating a story
with i mean it
i mean it
uh referring to the soul of america
i think that's likely mentioning nukes
in some capacity
using the term malarkey this idea is a
bunch of malarkey when he says i
shouldn't say this that's one of my
favorites that biden does where he sort
of goes you know these people they
really oh well i shouldn't i shouldn't
say it i shouldn't say it that i that's
that's one of my favorites reference to
inflation i think is quite plausible
talking about scranton
i love scranton mentions a republicans
not clapping for something obviously
good and like uncontroversial
referring to putin as a thug
talking about my friends on the other
side of the aisle using the phrase
here's the deal hold on do i have here's
the deal
i don't
um saying something is not a joke not a
joke referring to donald trump as my
predecessor announcing covet victory i
think it's almost certain he will do
some version of mission accomplished
using the phrase let me be clear let me
be clear
make no mistake is another one and
references to people's kitchen tables
joe biden often uses that rhetorical
tool talking about people's
conversations at the kitchen table
that is our bingo board for today and a
lot of people seem to be feeling very
confident very very confident
davidpakman.com
bingo you can generate your own bingo
board your own bingo board all right
thank you very much everybody
g bradbury says it would be awesome if
you could wish good luck to my wife sam
who is about to start an econ exam good
luck sam
sounds like a stupid question but what's
the difference between nato and the un
the u.n the you the united nations is i
would call it a political organization
of member nations
nato is a shared defense organization
specifically for shared defense so their
purpose is different
how epic would it be if biden gestures
to his ukrainian guest from the floor
and upstands president celensky that
would be interesting
what's your opinion on the clearly
racist rhetoric in western media when
talking about ukrainian versus other
refugees well it's it's just it's it's a
it's a form of racism yeah absolutely
there's no i don't know what else to say
if only hit his uh his noviture putin's
cup of tea make him die of totally
natural causes yes
david do you think russia plans to
restore the original empire by also
invading poland lithuania and romania
also will china invade taiwan i think
the latter is more likely
an incredibly powerful fifty dollar
super chat from hawkeye heyoka who says
love the show david glad i found it
thank you
thank you very very much you guys want
to see some stuff i have stuff
if you guys want to look at stuff
should we do it
here's some really funny stuff on tick
tock by the way you can follow us on
tick tock at david pakman show this is
these are our friends the good liars
here is a guy who thinks trump is still
president but still blames biden for
everything bad which is just it's pretty
good
so trump is the current president right
now yes sir so are you mad at trump for
the high gas prices no no no it's not
trump's fault he's who's whose fault is
it then it's joe it's he's got to set
all this job i didn't know where to
abide it he said he's not president he's
not the president okay what i'm trying
to say is so how could the gas prices be
his fault if he's if he's not president
what
you don't understand what they're trying
to do they have to wake up the
dingleberries that are still asleep
right okay
you you think that trump is actually
still in power right now wow so that's
uh that's that's pretty weaponized and
there's some really good ones
he's a piece of crap
yeah you don't like you to poison you
yeah yeah do you think that you think
vladimir putin is a bad guy yes yes
definitely yeah control freaks yeah
ukraine just to take his right power
grab steal people's land i mean
you already own russia what do you leave
people alone right and how would you
feel if somebody called him a genius
i'd feel sick yeah
i think that person that person probably
wouldn't be fit to lead right now
and i said this is genius
putin
the dude a big portion of the ukraine of
ukraine
putin declares it as independent oh
that's wonderful right what do you think
about vladimir putin so that's pretty
full on and here's one more
uh in 2024 a crazy thing happened and
biden were running against putin for
president of the united states who would
you vote for i would vote for putin
wow say
so that's pretty good that's the good
liars on tick tock and we have an
extremely explosive situation on tick
tock by the way if you're not following
us we've got to be close to
yeah close to 80k followers uh tick tock
is a great spot tick tock is a great
spot and there's these like very weirdly
angled dad video type angles
and um
there's a lot of crazy stuff one day i
had a very very big hair problem
uh in a tick tock i don't remember where
that is
was it here so i tweeted oh my god no
all right so anyway that's that's
tick-tock so we got that going on
um let me see what else i had for you
guys uh okay coveted restrictions we
already talked about oh listen to this
do you guys remember that completely
insane
canadian trucker convoy where they were
against mandates but not vaccines and
then it was coming to the united states
this was the culmination of the u.s
trucker convoy look at how insanely
embarrassing this is like just there's
no one here
this guy was talking to basically
himself
oh this video is not even playing see if
i got a different one here we go at
least that i used to raise my children
and provide for my family i had these
look at this there's two kids sitting
here just no one
think of the bad luck of you the trucker
convoy is stupid anyway because there's
there's almost no mandates left
and then
russia invades ukraine
and no one pays attention to your convoy
and the convoy is based on you being the
victim of tyranny as ukraine is getting
invaded just terrible timing for these
truck losers government officials coming
to me
to my face saying you may not be open
right huge red flag from the start
didn't make sense started reading the
bible more starting sorry getting the
constitution more something's off yep no
something's definitely off all right
here's another one um
why is this one not playing let's see
so that's number number one check this
out number two
i needed these cameras here i'm gonna be
straight up
i needed these cameras here well yeah i
mean there's no crowd because that's the
message i need you this is the message
that i need to get out they are here and
i need them to listen to what i'm about
to tell them that i just want to be
straight up from the start
so it didn't matter if one person showed
up
a million people showed up and one
person showed yeah i mean just a
humiliating failure we're just going to
be
we're just going to be cutting
things are going to get worse and i know
there's a lot of people here today
there's a lot of people watching that
have no there's not there's not a lot of
people here at all children
things are gonna dramatically in order
to have a lot of people there who have
children you need to have a lot of
people there change continue to
dramatically change and listen media and
you know what you see and what you hear
think about how
so far one way one thing is
so i have to tell you guys
i
love
that it went humiliatingly wrong like i
just i just love it am i a bad person
because i love that it went completely
bad and it just was a complete waste of
time to everybody involved
am i bad for that
i'm good oh no people are saying i'm
good it was the million maga rally i
know guys i know trump said it was the
biggest crowd he's ever seen
you never saw a bigger crowd than that
and we will ban men
super chat's coming in christopher says
is it plausible if republicans have both
houses that this proxy war continues
will republicans make it harder for the
president to age ukraine to push the
narrative democrats didn't do enough 110
absolutely christopher absolutely
david first time super chatter long time
watcher wondering what kind of espresso
machine and grinder you use i use the
breville
barista express with built-in grinder i
know a lot of people think that those
built-in grinders have real beta energy
but it's fine it's fine
um i've had it for
how long have i had it i've had it since
2016.
i've had it six years
let's do some math how much money do we
do we think i've saved by having this
espresso machine for six years let me
think about this
um let's see i typically make one
cappuccino
uh five days a week
and then maybe like four days a week
makes let's say i make i make nine
drinks
and then maybe my girlfriend has a
couple drinks let's just make it ten
let's say i make 10 drinks a week
okay
10 drinks a week times
6 years
times
let's do
45 weeks because i'm not home all the
time okay so that's 2 700 drinks
and then at this point most you know
kind of like the types of cafes i would
go to they really overcharge for
cappuccino let's say that they they
charge 425 so that's 11 000
worth of coffee at the retail price and
then i've got to figure out i think i
calculated that so let's see 11 475.
um i think i calculated each cappuccino
is about um
45 cents worth of milk
and 18 cents worth of beans
times 2 700. so my costs are 1701 okay
so i've got 11 475 worth of coffee
1701 in materials and the machine itself
was 600 bucks
so i've guys i've saved 9 100
it is much cheaper to make your coffee
at home folks that's just incredible oh
whoops did i put 60 months first okay so
i saved even more yeah it's crazy what's
going on sorry guys the math went
haywire
that was just some quick math
okay what internet browser do you use
and do you use an ad blocker i use
multiple browsers and yes i use an ad
blogger oh i didn't include the cost of
the water that's true
that's true
what was in the soccer ball putin gave
his boy donald j trump good question
uh all right
thank you everybody thank you welcome
welcome welcome and we continue to await
joe biden um expecting
all of this to start very soon here's a
little something for you mitch mcconnell
was
again given an opportunity to condemn
when trump called putin genius and smart
and he opted not to also mcconnell has a
really bad cough
you've long been critical of president
vladimir putin was it a mistake for the
former president to praise putin that's
very savvy smart is ukraine strategy
genius
what president putin is
is a ruthless thug
who's just invaded
invaded another sovereign country
and killed thousands of innocent people
that's what president putin is wow so
opting not to criticize donald trump for
calling putin savvy genius and smart
really struggling to speak mitch
mcconnell and we wish him absolutely the
best and hope that he is doing well
but he does not sound good does not
sound good i want to say thank you to
deborah smith
and pencey richardson who have signed up
on my website new members 32 and 33
and everybody watching on twitch welcome
welcome incredible people on twitch
getting twitch prime subscriptions
including chariot blonde beth graham
crimson elric who says please shout out
my my kids alex and julia alex and julia
welcome that's crimson elric
pr smoker and chomp suey
thank you for the support on twitch
uh putting us at 38 putting us at 38.
okay let's see what a few people in the
audience
think about
um tonight's state of the union address
uh i don't know what does whitney think
so the um
the emtc is in this category i'm not
sure if it's probably going to go for
like the 7 6 of the enneagram like
specifically no you're going to need a
protractor whitney you're going to need
a protractor
so i was doing some astrology and
um it says in the stars that the best
way is to lean western
and then you avoid the um the god of war
ooh pretty pretty weaponized checking in
is eric from massachusetts with some
disinformation
hey david it's sarah from mass are you
doing a live video on the state of the
union tonight because uh
wouldn't it be something surprise donald
trump walks out and he is your
president of the united states in exile
hey eric i would bet you you want to bet
on that let's bet who comes out and
gives the state of the union tonight i
would take even money i i'd even give
you odds that it's not trump who gives a
state of the union that's
you all know do you guys know i don't
really bet i'm not a betting man
that is a bet i would take that is a bet
i would take nicole says david love the
show side note what do you know about
your hoodie brand i have no idea
what is this let's see
uh
dear god i don't even know
it's called brush waffle i have no idea
i can't even see behind me because my
earpiece will come off
i i have no idea where this is from i'm
sorry i have no clue
don't leave read my last super chat
thank you
okay i don't i don't even know where it
is
um hi mom and david sur says stephen
chapman thank you stephen thank you
steven i very much appreciate you being
here
couple other super chats see what people
are thinking
about
the state of the union and um
different different things that
that are going on
mr pac-man sir many people are saying
how strongly the sweaters have been
looking on you from the standpoint of
sweater i would like to know the oranges
the oranges of where they originated oh
yeah that's the same question that was
just asked a lot of people i guess very
worried about my sweatshirt but
i don't know i i just i just don't know
well we know putin's nuts and he's
almost 70.
but today
i was listening to rachel maddow and
um clinton
uh
i guess she was secretary of state sorry
that i don't remember i think that's for
sure okay um one more from whitney
so i figured out what astrology sign is
like stuck in the middle where it's like
um it can't like halloween
um
to avoid war
it's the
um the gemini
guys it's gonna be a long night it's
going to be a very very long night bay
photo says sir you really need to
interview graham stefan for the show
i'd be interested i do have
two appearances to announce and i hope
that you guys will be supporting them
with peace and love i will be in florida
in two weeks and i will be appearing on
the patrick bet david show many people
have told me
we need a progressive on the patrick bet
david podcast and patrick bet david
tweeted i want a progressive on my show
and i said i'll do it and they said yes
so i will be in florida with patrick
betdavid and then i will be in florida
understand different part i will be in
florida
on anthony pompliano's
best business show best business show
so one appearance in florida another in
florida and it's going to be great more
information coming soon
david from the standpoint of state of
the union streams this is the best out
there shout out to my bud steven and
gent or gent who became fans welcome to
all of you thank you that bet is easy
money david think we'll get a close-up
of traders mansion and cinema tonight
maybe a little jab in the speech
maybe
we will see
whitney needs help can you configure
your voicemail to connect her to a
mental hotline when she calls oh that's
not appropriate
that's not appropriate david sir your
coffee budget is impressive from the
standpoint of cappuccino how do you like
yours how do you feel about having
cappuccino after 11am yeah i think it's
f i'm not i'm not big on this no
cappuccino after 11am rule
um i know that there's a lot of opinions
about doing that
yeah
but i don't really have a problem i
don't really have a problem with
cappuccino in the afternoon when will
rogan have putin on his show
that's a fair question i don't know
i don't know
but i would i mean listen
i would watch that
i would watch that
um all right folks people are starting
to file in
to the chamber
as we await the state of the union
address technically many of you wrote to
me and said david i remember you
covering biden's state of the union last
year
why are they saying this is the first
one
traditionally as we see senate majority
leader charles schumer there
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
vermont senator patrick leahy iowa
senator chuck grassley
someone with a mask there's joni ernst
iowa senator
uh
i'll do my best to call people out as i
see them typically when a president is
inaugurated in january and then gives a
speech in february or march
they don't call it a state of the union
they just call it a joint address that's
the tradition
so that's what it is there is joe
manchin a vile guy guys i'm gonna say
something and i hope no please don't
cancel me for this i just want to float
this idea i saw mansion and mitt romney
there
if you say to me
either mansion or romney will be
president
i don't know that i go with mansion
i think maybe i go with romney i know
mansion's a democrat and romney's a
republican but
isn't mitt romney
orders of magnitude brighter than joe
manchin and at least seems to have
clear morality and how far he will go
even if i disagree with him about so
many things i don't know guys i think i
go with romney over mansion i really do
oh god 20 tool cells just canceled their
membership dear god
all right well i don't take it back i
don't think right romney at least stands
for something something i mostly don't
like but mansion is i just really don't
like mansion i really don't like mansion
um
all right
very good so we're gonna keep uh we're
gonna keep an eye on all of this i wish
we oh here we go here's a clean feed as
i like to call it beautiful so there is
mansion and uh willard mitt romney amy
klobuchar is right behind
as you can see there she is dressed in
blue very very strongly standing
strongly you'll notice that no masks
mostly no masks being worn washington dc
ended their indoor mask mandate and most
attendees
testing was required most taking
advantage of the no mask requirement
i enjoyed the coffee cost breakdown
thanks for live streams thank you chris
appreciate having you here appreciate
you having having you here very much
um
yes so okay let's
i'm gonna do what we call a reset just
because so so much is going on and so
many people have joined
welcome to everybody watching on youtube
twitch and facebook youtube twitch and
facebook
in just about 20 minutes not even
joe biden will enter
the house of representatives and deliver
his state of the union address to a a
sort of joint session of the house and
senate although it's not clear
everybody's attending well joe manchin
almost just fell down did you guys
notice that
he almost just took a [ __ ] there that
was that was that could have been really
i mean
it the angle he was at i think his head
was going right into one of those seats
and it could have completely upended the
entire night
um
joe biden will speak at the top of the
hour
and then the republicans will give a
response now i heard marjorie taylor
greene was giving the response but that
can't possibly be right
no no no iowa uh
no it's iowa governor kim reynolds maybe
marjorie taylor green is giving like
some other response let me see marjorie
taylor green
response state of the union
no not even i don't even know what she's
doing
i don't even know what she's doing
so there's joe manchin once again
uh you see the vice president kamala
harris on the left speaker of the house
nancy pelosi on the right
um that's the agenda for today if you
want to play joe biden bingo this is
equal opportunism guys the people mad at
me for doing bingo with biden
guys
you don't think i'm so partisan that i
would only do bingo with trump do you i
hope you think better of me than that
davidpakman.com bingo you can generate
your own bingo card and we'll play along
um
once the once the speech starts it's
just fun guys it's just fun all right
davidpakman.com
bingo there's general mark milley
who was attacked as being a woke general
because he said hey
some people believe in critical race
theory so the military should at least
know what it is
wow
what a controversial statement you know
who else do we have here here's lindsey
graham lindsey graham here senator from
south carolina
uh here's mark warner virginia senator a
lot of folks filing in
dignitaries of all sorts not really
number of different people
super chats are pouring in why is it so
easy richard asks to sell the masses on
anti-semitism and jewish conspiracies
why is it the the go-to a lot of people
so a couple different reasons number one
oh hey here's our friend uh congressman
mcgovern he's a good guy so i'm at a
coffee shop recently um a lot of people
don't know anything about jews so that
makes them potentially a viable target
number two
there are people who
don't see jews as off-limit because
they're like oh jews do fine and they're
white passing and of course it's like
okay ashkenazi jews are mostly white
passing not mizrahim and safar demon so
that's another reason that it's sort of
like it's a minority group but it's one
that's supposedly privileged by certain
definitions so that that makes it a
popular target as well
um and you know at a certain point
there's kind of like the if every if you
only have a hammer everything looks like
a nail here's our friend congressman
eric swalwell friend of the show
follower of the david pakman show
very good guy
um
sir your voicemails would be perfect for
a talking filibuster i know we could
just uh
we could just set sydney up and just say
go
so what i love about this situation is
that it shows the difference between
like
um donald trump and
his quote supports
because i feel like
people were like not that supportive of
donald trump they were like using his
power to be like really anyway we i
could do we could do two one or two
things guys i'm sorry whitney not sydney
i can do an hour of biden speaking this
the state of the union or i can do an
hour of whitney voicemails what would
you guys prefer
what do people want
willing to do either as people okay
this is this is the ukrainian guest and
guys i forget who it is remind me who
this is
i forget who this guest is it was a big
deal
does anybody remember
let me look it up
is that the ukrainian ambassador
that's the ukrainian ambassador that's
aksana markharova oksana markarova here
is ted cruz one of the most vile and
disgusting people on this
in this country i get a minimum i don't
know about planet
um
i believe this is senator blumenthal
here
there's willard mitt romney and joe
manchin they're really buddy buddy it
seems
a lot lot going on
lisa murkowski or kirsten cinema as
president oof
i think i still think cinema i mean
cinema still i think vote mostly votes
the right way whereas murkowski even
though she would sometimes criticize
trump still mostly voted with trump so i
think on that one i have to go with
cinema i do think so
i do think so
uh other super chats coming in david sir
if putin concedes the war with ukraine
what do you think is the best case
scenario for him in russia
um probably 10 years of economic turmoil
i'm reading reports economic reports
that what is happening to russia now
could be 10 or 20 years
of economic turmoil
can you imagine
that is
wow
david sir
you were the best sir your wife is up in
the air thank you
um okay i think we got most of these
super chats covered i appreciate that if
you're just joining us we are uh we're
gonna have uh some time together tonight
as we have two speeches we have joe
biden state of the union then we'll have
the republican response we're also
monitoring what is happening in kiev and
other parts of ukraine because there was
the expectation that quite literally as
joe biden takes the stage
the bombing would ramp up and you really
hate to see it
and there's going to be a lot
uh
about ukraine in tonight's speech also
expecting some kind of a claim of
victory over covid
um
mike pillow not invited not invited i i
believe that
the blue and yellow here
uh and the other people wearing that
bright blue i i believe it's an homage
to the ukrainian flag i do believe that
and i really believe it strongly
am i familiar with myers-briggs and
enneagram yes yes i i just i find it
really boring i do it's almost like
astrology to me
i find it really boring but
i know a lot of people are big on it
okay i'm sorry guys i have skipped
thanking a whole bunch of different
people
let me say thank you too oh boy there's
some names here that are problematic
chief boris nick lovin jiggy grimface
milil firewall c missile creeping willow
the dark mock rises my bag of kiwis
crazy turts that's 11
twitch prime subscribers
and i'm going to take this opportunity
to make my one oh here's ruben gallego
who's been a guest on the program a lot
of friends of the show in the audience
guys i'm going to take this opportunity
to make one request of you guys
for all that is good
and reasonable
i invite you to get a membership on my
website joinedpakman.com although
although many of you are here very
strongly supporting us there is an
entire contingent that is trying to
destroy us and are cancelling their
memberships one such person
is this tool cell the tool sees are very
very mad
robert wrote to me and said i have
unsubscribed from your show
because you revealed your our tribal
you look for labels you follow the
liberal official narrative and robert
writes
tulsi gabbard
speaks to citizens of all labels
this is a tool cell
i say
go away i'm fine losing the tulsi people
because i believe
that we can get the folks back so i
invite you
okay they're doing their preliminaries
join pacman.com
the coupon code is please don't war it's
an anti-war message and as an extra
incentive see how we're at 49 new
members today whoever's number 50 i will
send you a free item from my online
store to anywhere in the world coffee
mug
hat
hoodie shirt whatever you want whoever
is next okay join pacman.com we're at
49.
if you're 50
you get the free item and that's even if
you use the discount code please don't
war every single one of you will get a
thank you let's listen
the gentleman from maryland mr hoyer
the gentleman from south carolina mr
clyburn
the gentleman from massachusetts the
gentlewoman from massachusetts ms clark
the gentleman from new york mr jeffries
the gentleman from new york these
preliminaries are actually quite
irrelevant and and pretty boring so
we're going to uh we're we're going to
stand by at this point in time i i'm not
i'm not so sure we need
that necessarily
sir from the ten standpoint of tiny
hands do you believe that mind fuhrer
trump really will run again i am
strongly fearing if he does
uh i think trump's intention is to run
again i wonder whether his health will
keep him from running
everybody wondering about bingo yes
davidpakman.com
bingo for your biden bingo card
play along davidpakman.com
bingo
do you do you think destroying the
russian economy could backfire gives
putin someone to blame and may give rise
to someone even worse
i don't think it will give rise to
someone even worse
but anytime you destroy a country's
economy there are of course risks of
course
david who does the right have any more
who are at least credible and honest the
only one i can think of is george will
maybe douglas murray i don't know about
douglas murray
there aren't too many people
there aren't too many people
there really aren't
um
i i mean i guess that i'd have to think
of a list
sir did you see ukrainian authorities
tipped off about the plot by members of
russia's federal security service who do
not support the war i did and i'm going
to cover that story tomorrow apparently
an assassination plot against zelensky
was foiled
and apparently members of russia's fsb
were partially to thank for that
incredible
do you find yourself saying sir a lot in
everyday life outside of the show
never
never sir sure
i really i really don't
um
i do when when my girlfriend asked me to
do something i will tell her sometimes
that i'm going to look into that
strongly looking at that very strongly
but i never i'm never using sir outside
of the show
please don't use profanity and cuss
while streaming or cancel my membership
thanks yeah dude see that that's that's
that's just i i
that really pisses me off that's just so
stupid okay
this is an adult show sometimes there's
profanity it's
can't go go ahead and cancel it is
someone willing to replace this guy's
membership
is someone willing to replace this guy
guys
you think because you pay two bucks a
month you're gonna take over my show and
tell me now i can't you're gonna
language police nobody's willing to
replace them okay that's too bad okay
please don't cancel i thought someone
was gonna be willing to replace you but
i guess not um
okay now if there were if they were
trolling then it's it's all a joke if
they were trolling new member number 50
today getting a free item from my store
is victor munoz
number 50.
victor please email me info
davidpakman.com
and i will get you your free item
memberships are dumping in
thank you to the following people i can
barely keep up guys i'm going to do
everything i can
creeping willow dark mock right oh no
sorry these people i think
f can wrecked gen here ish paul singh
lord zelig
try gamer
x vine hoosier daddy jen jang robots
tamps open bar funeral gen here odw's
ambitious jer harkinan skittle stew god
kong plasma rifle with two
that's putting us at 64. guys i'll give
away another item to number 75. i can't
even keep up with what's going on we may
already be there let's see here edward
helbling is a new member on my website
luke sevilla
carlos escamilla
tyler maxwell
kyle svengross is 69.
um
phoebe porter
and jay peterson jay peterson of
seinfeld fame thank you
uh aisha mitchell
puts us at 72. all right 75 is getting
an item from me asa asba
jean donnat
and ryan cantos is number 75 ryan if you
would like a free item from my online
store email info davidpakman.com
uh guitar goddess just gifted five
memberships manger poutine and super
sicky as well as skittle stew popping in
that puts us at 82.
man what do you guys think i'll uh next
free item at 100. i i quite literally
can barely keep up with what's happening
on my website
let me see here let's see if we're
already there mandy copeland is number
83 bob loftis is number 84. max close is
85. cami swann is new member number 86.
the website might not be able to hold it
captain jessie knight is number 87.
shafen vong is number 88
matt chavez is 89 ryan hamburg is number
90.
uh
taylor wolff is number 91 using the
coupon code obama
william bellamy is number 92
jason knight is
antonio de la pena 94.
mindy thompson is number 95. all right
number 100 let's see here we go
john davis
is number 96
gabriel arnego is number 97 jennifer
hudson is number 98 sean nixon is number
99 as the supreme court one of the most
weaponized conservative supreme courts
in the last many decades is entering the
chamber
number 100 today is mitchell slagowski
mitchell
you've got yourself a free item you can
email info davidpakman.com if you would
like to collect it
um phased plasma rifle sterling's
kitchen has given away five also thanks
to final heaven
oh and phased plasma giving away another
five
i think that's 112. dear god i i don't i
don't know that i can even keep up with
this stuff
jaylen tucker is new member 113
scott genn
is number 114
let's do a free item at 123. thanks to
william townsend i i just i mean these
are coming in faster than i can say
people's names simon freed
edgar santana puts us at 117.
thanks to craig lawrence
and brandon welch 119
all right let's join the state of the
union here
here is uh dr jill biden
many republicans quick to recognize that
she is not a medical doctor
doesn't really tell you much dr mehmet
oz is a medical doctor and he
recommended drinking silver so
apparently the md alone doesn't really
make you competent
thanks to progressively progressly
stoned
and phased plasma rifle
putting us at 121.
super chat's continuing to come in
the shirt you're wearing slaps harder
than the beatles dog yeah three comments
on my hoodie
if it gets bad i might even put the hood
on
this isn't it's not a bad look
oh god cables everywhere
see what else we got here
madam speaker the president's cabinet
cabinet is coming in
tara dunn is new member in 122. andrew
kaiser is 123.
bill mckibben
could it be that bill mckibben bill
mckibben is number 124
[Applause]
wow very very strongly here's anthony
blinken
and lloyd austin
everybody come on in don't be shy don't
be shy i see people coming in and saying
am i welcome here everybody's welcome
just don't troll
wow
this is actually not very comfortable
[Applause]
big thank you to keely valero as well as
christine parker and alex pingree people
are wondering what's going on
the tulsi people are weaponizing their
memberships and canceling here's
transportation secretary pete budege
um so we have a coupon code please don't
war and i sort of politely asked people
to maybe get a membership on my website
and over a hundred people have done it
and the website can barely even keep up
couple masks still in there
thanks to david p for the membership and
term three
at 1 29.
thanks to deb tudor nikki dell
morgan moynihan omar diaz and nelson
camacho for the membership i really
appreciate you guys i really do
such great people we have in our
audience today
really amazing
very very much so
um
joe biden expected any moment
we will be here for the state of the
union and then we will have the
republican response there is janet
yellen the treasury secretary speaking
to anthony blinken
welcome julie elizabeth and cat's wife
with the twitch prime subscriptions very
much appreciate you guys as well uh
twitch has been amazing lately
which has been amazing lately we're so
glad to be on the platform
some other super chats coming in
blow up kavanaugh's car unfortunately we
cannot allow that i do have to remove
that uh we do not advocate violence we
cannot do it
we could get into serious trouble
brett kavanaugh is a disgusting human
being we can say that
brett kavanaugh is horrifying he is
everything we should aspire never to be
but we're not going to say blow up his
car we're not going to do that okay we
do have
there's only certain things we can call
for here and we will ban men that's out
of bounds too
that's out of bounds too we're not going
to do any of it
david you always speak so deliberately
or only when you broadcast love your
show it would be an honor if you read
this hmm i don't know about the answer
to that
i'm not sure i always want to be
understood
what it really is is you know i'm from
argentina as some of you know
and growing up
uh
okay there's there's some people getting
getting a little edgy in the chat
growing up i was around a lot of people
who
the language i was speaking to them in
was their second language and so i just
developed the habit of trying to speak
as clearly as possible to be understood
over under republican starter let's go
brandon chant they're not going to do
that they're not going to do that but we
do have bingo if you want something fun
to do during the speech go to
davidpakman.combingo and you can
generate your own bingo card with the
items i put together
uh here's lindsey graham and ted cruz
susan collins from maine as you can see
this is brett kavanaugh and i think
is that is this amy kovet barrett right
here i think that's who that is
um
i will try to call squares as we go yeah
thank you to aaron obama
for the new membership
jose rodriguez has just signed up on my
website laura singer and peter zinerko
all new members putting us at 140.
also thank you to hayley vox
zanox the ark
for the twitch prime subscriptions
remember if you have amazon prime you
can get a twitch prime subscription for
free you're basically just taking five
bucks from jeff bezos
i i i wouldn't leave the money with
bezos i would i would take it
sir david please tell my my girlfriend
michelle hello hey michelle great to
have you here
it feels like the qgp response is as bad
as the trolls in chat lately we have
been overrun with trolls
we are banning people
all the time
and we just it's like uh it's like
playing whack-a-mole it really is
it's it's horrifying what's going on
with the trolls
um welcome to tgs74 over on twitch very
much appreciate that
super chat yeah we'll keep super chats
up during the entire uh
during the entire speech why not
uh brian tyler cohen sent in an email
and he got an interview with biden
interesting i should send an email i
wish i knew to who
sabathia says obama james says five
okay
general mark millie
we are moments from the speech uh the
speech expected to go i think about 70
minutes is my instinct
but we will see we will see welcome to
hedgehog cridler and shield and evil
who uh just grabbed twitch prime
subscriptions appreciate you guys very
much also welcome to delbert layal new
member number 147 today
nancy pelosi as the
uh speaker of the house will welcome joe
biden momentarily and he will enter the
chamber
he will
certainly speak about the situation in
ukraine and russia expected to sort of
declare victory over kovid he will
likely address inflation he is going to
propose at least one new policy
initiative from what i've read
shot x thomas is new member number 148
today
free item at 150. yeah let's do it well
blake beyond blake beyond his new member
149 today let's do it guys see how we're
at 150 here
new member sorry we're almost at 1 50.
whoever is new member 150 on my website
gets a free item from my online store
madam speaker
the president of the united states
there's the house of representatives
sergeant-at-arms announcing
president joe biden
who will give what is officially his
first state of the union address his
second address before a joint session of
congress last i believe it was last
march he did speak
but it is not called the state of the
union that first time around
not called the state of the union
can we throw a banana peel in front of
kavanaugh maybe that's oka okay
do you think putin would consider it an
act of aggression to send him uncharged
pickles
uh probably yeah uncharged piccolos
sorry to hear about the trolls david
appreciate your coverage been a member
for a while
thank you ryan
i have to tell you the applause is a bit
more
scant
than typically during this portion of
the walk-in
it's tepid exactly
did he even say a word to amy kovabera
it didn't look like it there
lana kagan
general mark milley
everybody standing very strongly
okay real quick remember 150s benjamin
woods emailed me for your free item but
we're right in the heart of it now
members of congress i have the high
privilege and distinct honor of
presenting to you the president of the
united states
a lot of this stuff is very perfunctory
at this point everybody claps but if
you've never seen one of these before
later there will be very partisan
moments where only democrats will clap
but here
the etiquette is that everybody claps
and that is what everybody's doing even
ted cruz it's it's quite literally a
please clap moment
thank you all very much
thank you
thank you
thank you all very very much
thank you
please
thank you so much
[Applause]
madam speaker
madam vice president our first lady and
second gentleman
members of congress in the cabinet
justice of the supreme court
my fellow americans
last year covet 19 kept us apart
this year we're finally together again
tonight
the might we meet as democrats
republicans independents
but most importantly
as americans
with the duty to one another
to america
to the american people to the
constitution
and an unwavering resolve
that freedom will always triumph over
tyranny
thank you
six days ago
russia's vladimir putin sought to shake
the very foundations of the free world
thinking he could make it bend
to his menacing ways
but he badly miscalculated
he thought he could roll into ukraine
and the world would roll over
instead he met with a mall a wall of
strength he never anticipated or
imagined he met the ukrainian people
and president
zlinski
to every ukrainian their fearlessness
their courage their determination
literally inspires the world
groups of citizens
blocking tanks with their bodies
everyone from students to retirees to
teachers turned soldiers defending their
homeland
and in this struggle president zielinski
said in his speech to the european
parliament
light will win over darkness
the ukrainian ambassador of the united
states is here tonight sitting with the
first lady
let each of us if you're able to stand
stand and send an unmistakable signal to
the world
wow
thank you
thank you thank you thank you
the greatest strong she's resolved
it does seem republicans have decided
it's probably better to support ukraine
at least from a pr perspective stand
with the ukrainian people
throughout our history
we've learned this lesson
when dictators do not pay a price for
their aggression they cause more chaos
they keep moving
and the costs the threats to the america
and america to the world
keeps rising
that's why the nato alliance was created
to secure peace and stability in europe
after world war ii
the united states is a member along with
29 other nations
it matters
american diplomacy matters
american resolve matters
putin's latest attack on ukraine
was premeditated
and totally unprovoked
he rejected repeated repeated efforts at
diplomacy
he thought the west and nato wouldn't
respond
he thought he could divide us at home in
this chamber in this nation
he thought he could divide us in europe
as well
but putin was wrong
we are ready we are united and that's
what we did we stayed united we prepared
extensively and carefully we spent
months building coalitions of other
freedom-loving nations in europe and the
americas to america to the asian and
african continents
to confront putin
like many of you i spent countless hours
unifying your european allies
we shared with the world in advance what
we knew putin was planning and precisely
how we would try to falsify
and justify his aggression
we countered russia's lies with the
truth
and now
now that he's acted
the three free world was holding him
accountable
along with 27 members of the european
union including france germany italy as
well as countries like the united
kingdom canada japan korea australia new
zealand and many others even switzerland
are inflicting pain on russia
and supporting the people of ukraine
putin is now isolated from the world
more than he has ever been
together
all true but literally as this is
happening the bombing continues and
something's going to have to give
together along with our allies we are
right now enforcing powerful economic
sanctions
we're cutting off russia's largest banks
in the international financial system
preventing russia's central bank from
defending the russell
ruble making putin 630 billion dollar
war fund worthless
we're choking russia's access
to choking russia's access to technology
that will sap its economic strength and
weaken its military for years to come
tonight
i say to the russian oligarchs and the
corrupt leaders who built billions of
dollars off this violent regime no more
the united states
i mean it
the united states
department of justice is assembling a
dedicated task force to go after the
crimes of the russian oligarchs
we're joining with european allies to
find and seize their yachts their luxury
apartments their private jets
we're coming for you ill-begotten gains
and tonight i'm announcing that we will
join our allies in closing off american
airspace to all russian flights further
isolation wow
and adding additional squeeze on their
economy
major step
americans in russia that want to get
home are going to have trouble
he has no idea what's coming
the ruble has already lost 30 percent of
its value
the russian stock market has lost 40
percent of its value
and trading remains suspended
the russian economy is reeling
and putin alone is the one to blame
together with our allies
we're providing support to the
ukrainians in their fight for freedom
military assistance
economic assistance humanitarian
assistance we're giving more than a
billion dollars of direct assistance
ukraine and will continue to aid
ukrainian people as they defend their
country and help ease their suffering
but let me be clear
our forces are not
engaged and will not engage in the
conflict with russian forces in ukraine
our forces are not going to europe to
fight ukraine but to defend our nato
allies in the event that putin decides
to keep moving west
for that purpose we have mobilized
american ground forces air squadrons
ship deployments to protect nato
countries including poland romania
latvia lithuania and estonia and as i've
made crystal clear
the united states and our allies will
defend every inch of territory that is
nato territory for the full force of our
collective power every single inch
even degenerate steve scalise cheering
for that
and we're clear-eyed
ukrainians are fighting back with pure
courage
but the next few days weeks and months
will be hard on them
putin has unleashed violence and chaos
but while he may make gains on the
battlefield he'll pay a continuing high
price over the long run
and a pound of ukrainian people the
proud proud people pound for pound ready
to fight with every inch of earned
energy they have a pound of ukrainians
is not that many people but
have repeatedly shown that they will not
tolerate anyone who tries to take their
country backwards
to all americans
i'll be honest with you as i always
promised i would be
a russian dictator of
invading a foreign country has cost
around the world
and i'm taking robust action to make
sure the pain of our sanctions is
targeted at russian economy
and that we use every tool at our
disposal to protect american businesses
and consumers
tonight
i can announce the united states has
worked with 30 other countries to
release 60 million barrels of oil from
reserves around the world
america
will lead that effort
we only see 30 million barrels of our
own strategic petroleum reserve
and we stand ready to do more if
necessary united with our allies
these steps will help blunt gas prices
here at home
but i know news about what's happening
can seem alarming to all americans
but i want you to know
we're going to be okay
we're going to be okay
when the history of this era is written
putin's war in ukraine will have left
russia weaker and the rest of the world
stronger
and while it shouldn't
while it shouldn't have taken
well it shouldn't have taken something
so terrible for people around the world
to see what's at stake
now everyone sees it clearly
we see the unity among leaders of
nations
a more unified europe a more unified
west
we see unity among the people who are
gathering in cities
and large crowds around the world even
in russia to demonstrate their support
for the people of ukraine
in the battle between democracy and
autocracies
democracies are rising to the moment
and the world is clearly choosing the
side of peace and security
this is the real test
and it's going to take time
so let us continue to draw inspiration
from the iron will of the ukrainian
people
to our fellow ukrainian americans
who forge the deep bond that connects
our two nations
we stand with you we stand with you
putin may circle keeve with tanks but
it'll never gain the hearts and souls of
the iranian people he'll never iranian
freedom
and he will never never weaken the
resolve of the free world
there's our friend derek swalwell
in an america that has lived through
two of the hardest years this nation has
ever faced
the pandemic has been punishing
and so many families are living paycheck
to paycheck struggling to keep up with
the rising cost of food gas housing and
so much more
i understand like many of you did
my dad had to leave his home in scranton
pennsylvania to find work
so like many of you i grew up in a
family when the price of food went up it
was felt throughout the family it had an
impact
that's one of the first things i did as
president was fight to pass the american
rescue plan
because people were hurting
we needed to act and we did
few pieces of legislation have done more
at a critical moment in our history to
lift us out of a crisis
it fueled our efforts to vaccinate the
nation and combat covert 19.
does this count as a dad's story i'm not
sure americans
it helped put food on the table remember
those long lines of cars waiting for
hours just to get a box of food put in
their trunk yeah
it cut the cost of health care insurance
and as my dad used to say it gave the
people there's a little bit of breathing
room there it is
unlike the two trillion dollar tax cut
passed in the previous administration
that benefited the top one percent of
americans the american rescue plan
[Music]
oh
the american rescue plan oh my god chuck
schumer
chuck schumer setting the record for
cringe
oh my god
and it worked
guys i've got chicken skin from that
it worked you created jobs lots of jobs
in fact our economy created over
6.5 million new jobs just last year
more jobs
in one year
than ever before in the history of the
united states of america
the economy grew at a rate of 5.7 last
year the republicans don't like it in 40
years
and the first step in bringing
fundamental change to our economy that
hasn't worked for working people in this
nation for too long
for the past 40 years
we were told
that tax break for those of the top and
benefits would trickle down and everyone
would would benefit but that
trickle-down theory led to a weaker
economic growth
lower wages bigger deficits and a
widening gap between the top
and everyone else in
nearly a century
look
vice president harris and i ran for
office and i realized we had fundamental
disagreements on this but ran for office
of the new economic vision for america
invest in america
educate americans
grow the workforce build the economy
from the bottom up in the middle out not
from the top down because we know
because we know
because we know when the middle class
grows
when the middle class grows the poor of
a way up and the wealthy do very well
america used to have the best roads
bridges and airports on earth
and now
our infrastructure is ranked 13th in the
world
won't be able to compete for the jobs of
the 21st century if we don't fix it
that's why i was so important guys sorry
to interrupt this is cracking me up my
husband is playing a drinking game with
the bingo card he's going to be
plastered by the end of this
to invest
rebuild america
the single biggest investment
in history
it was a bipartisan effort and i want to
thank the members of both parties who
work to make it happen
we're done talking about infrastructure
weeks we're now talking about an
infrastructure
decade
look
republicans don't want the
infrastructure
it's going to transform america
to put us in a path to win the economic
competition of the 21st century that we
face with the rest of the world
particularly china
i've told xi jinping
it's never been a
good we'll create good jobs for millions
of americans modernizing roads airports
ports waterways all across america this
guy's gross we will do it
to withstand the devastating impacts of
climate change and promote environmental
justice
we'll build a national network of 500
000 electric vehicle charging stations
nice begin to replace the poisonous lead
pipes so every child every american has
clean water to drink at home and at
school
going to provide
provide affordable
high-speed internet for every american
rural suburban urban and tribal
communities
four thousand projects have already been
announced many of you have announced
them in your districts
and tonight
i'm announcing that this year
we will start fixing over sixty five
thousand miles of highway and one
thousand 500 bridges in disrepair
much needed
imagine not cheering for fixing bridges
after we just had a collapse
we're going to do it by buying america
buy american products
support american jobs
the federal government
spends about 600 billion a year to keep
this country safe and secure
there's been a law on the books for
almost a century to make sure taxpayers
dollars support american jobs and
businesses
every administration democrat and
republican says they'll do it
but we're actually we're actually doing
it
we'll buy america to make sure every
everything from the deck of an aircraft
carrier to the steel on highway guard
rails is made in america from beginning
to end all of it all gonna cost money
our economy is based on getting cheaper
stuff from china
to compete for the jobs
of the future we also need a loving
playing field
with china
and other competitors
that's why it's so important to pass the
bipartisan innovation act sitting in
congress that will make record
investments in emerging technologies in
american manufacturing
we used to invest almost 2 percent of
our gdp in research and development
we don't now
can't
china is
let me give you one example why it's so
important to pass
if you travel 20 miles each of columbus
ohio
you'll find a thousand empty acres of
land
it won't look like much
but if you stop and look closely
you'll see a field of dreams
the ground in which america's future
will be built
that's where intel the american company
that helped build silicon valley
is going to build a 20 billion dollar
semiconductor mega site
up to eight state-of-the-art factories
in one place
10 000 new jobs
in those factories the average job about
135
135 000 a year
some most sophisticated manufacturing in
the world
to make con
computer chips the size of a fingertip
the power of the world and everyday
lives
from smartphones technology the internet
technology has yet to be invented
but that's just the beginning
intel ceo pat gelsinger who was here
tonight i know where pat is pat there
you go pat stand up
i don't know the ceo of india he didn't
create microchips i mean i don't know
ceo of intel this much applause
pat came to see me and he told me
they're ready to increase their
investment from 20 billion
to 100 billion
that would be the biggest investment in
manufacturing in american history
and all they're waiting for is for you
to pass this bill
so let's not wait any longer
send it to my desk i'll sign it
and we'll really take off in a big way
right
and folks
intel is not alone kevin mccarthy on his
phone i guess he can't be bothered
america
just look around and you'll see an
amazing story
the rebirth of pride that comes from
stamping products made in america the
revitalization of american manufacturing
companies are choosing to build new
factories here
when just a few years ago they would
have gone overseas
that's what's happening
ford is investing 11 billion dollars in
electric vehicles creating 11 000 jobs
across the country
gm is making the largest investment in
history
seven billion dollars to build electric
vehicles creating 4 000 jobs in michigan
right all told
369 000 new manufacturing jobs were
created in america last year alone
folks
oh man
powered by people i've met like jojo
burgess
from generations of union steel workers
in pittsburgh who's here us tonight
where are you jojo
there you go thanks buddy
as ohio
as ohio senator sherrod brown says
[Applause]
this kid is the the star man i love this
kid he says it's time to build a man the
handshake rust bell
it's time
to see
the
the what used to be called the rust belt
become this the the home of a
significant resurgence of manufacturing
and with all the bright spots in our
economy
record job growth higher wages too many
families are struggling to keep up with
their bills true inflation
is robbing them of gains they thought
otherwise they would be able to feel
i get it
that's why my top priority is getting
prices under control look
our economy roared back faster than
almost anyone predicted but pandemic
meant that businesses
had a hard time hiring enough people
because of the pandemic to keep up
production in their factories
so she didn't have people making those
beams that went in the buildings because
they were out the factory was closed
the panic also disrupted the global
supply chain
factories close
when that happens it takes longer to
make goods and get them to the
warehouses to the stores and go prices
go up
look at cars last year right one third
of all the inflation was because of
automobile sales there weren't enough
semiconductors to make all the cars that
people wanted to buy
and guess what
prices of automobiles went way up
especially used vehicles as well but
and so we have a choice
one way to fight inflation is to drive
down wages and make americans poorer
i think i have a better idea to fight
inflation
lower your costs not your wages
folks
that means make more cars than
semiconductors in america
more infrastructure and innovation in
america
more goods moving faster and cheaper in
america
more jobs where you can earn a good
living in america
instead of relying on foreign supply
chains let's make it in america
look
economist
i mean listen guys everybody loves the
make it in america stuff but our entire
economy is based on not making it here
because it's expensive increasing the
productive capacity of our company our
economy
i call it
building a better america
my plan
to fight inflation
will lower your cost and lower the
deficit
17 nobel laureates in economics said my
plan will ease long-term inflationary
pressures top business leaders
and i believe most americans support the
plan and here's the plan
first
cut the cost of prescription drugs
we pay more
for the same drug
producing republicans sitting they don't
want to cut they maybe they want to
increase the cost
just look at insulin
one in 10 americans has diabetes
in virginia i met a 13 year old boy the
handsome young man standing up here
joshua davis
he and his dad both have type 1 diabetes
means they need insulin every single day
insulin costs about ten dollars of vial
tonight let him explain why the kid's
there first
the pharmaceutical company
but drug companies charge families like
joshua and his dad up to 30 times that
amount
i spoke with joshua's mom
imagine what it's like to look at your
child
who needs insulin to stay healthy
and have no idea how in god's name
you're going to be able to pay for it
what it does to your family but what it
does to your dignity
your ability to look your child in the
eye
to be the parent you expect yourself to
be
i really mean to think about that
that's what i think about
you know
yesterday josh was here tonight but
yesterday was his birthday happy
birthday buddy by the way
for joshua
and 200 000 other young people with type
1 diabetes
let's cap the cost of insulin 35 a month
so everyone can afford it
and drug companies will do very very
well they're propping margin
while we're at it i know we have great
disagreements on this floor with this
let's let medicare negotiate the price
of prescription drugs
they already
set the price for va drugs
look the american rescue plan is helping
millions of families with affordable
care act plans to save them twenty four
hundred dollars a year on their health
programs let's close the coverage gap
and make these savings permanent
and second
let's cut energy costs for families
an average of 500 a year by combating
climate change let's provide an
investment tax credits to weatherize
your home and your business
to be energy efficient and get a tax
credit for it
double america's clean energy production
and solar wind and so much more lower
the price of electric vehicles saving
another eighty dollars a month that
you're not going to have to pay at the
pump
right
third
the third thing we can do to change the
standard of living for hard-working
folks
is cut the cost of child care
cut the cost of child care
folks
if you live in a major city in america
you pay up to 14 000 a year for child
care per child
i was a single dad for five years
raising two kids i had a lot of help
though
i had a mom a dad
a brother and a sister that really
helped
but middle class and working folks
shouldn't have to pay more than seven
percent of their income to care for the
young children
my plan
my plan would cut the cost
of child care in half for most families
and help parents including millions of
women who left the workforce during the
pandemic because they couldn't afford
child care
to be able to get back to work
generating economic growth
but my plan doesn't stop there it also
includes home and long-term care more
affordable housing
pre-k for three and four-year-old
all these will lower costs for families
and under my plan nobody let me say this
again nobody earning less than 400 000 a
year will pay an additional penny in new
taxes not a single penny wow
so it seems like he's sort of
revitalizing the idea of doing tax
reform which is going to be very tough
maybe wrong
but my guess is if we took a secret
ballot in this floor
that we'd all agree that the president
tax system
ain't fair
we have to fix it
i'm not looking to punish anybody
but let's make corporations and wealthy
americans start paying their fair share
look
last year
last year
unlike chris coons and tom carper
and my distinguished congresswoman
we come from the land of corporate
america there are more corporations
incorporated in america than every other
state in america combined
i still won 36 years in a row
the point is
even they understand they should pay
just a fair share last year 55 of the
fortune 500 companies
earned 40 billion dollars in profit and
paid zero in front did he mean in
delaware
now look
it's not fair
that's why i proposed a 15 minimum tax
rate for corporations
we've got
and that's why
in the g7 other meetings overseas we're
able to put together i was able to be
somewhat helpful 130 countries degree on
a global minimum tax rate
so companies can't get out of paying
their taxes at home by shipping jobs in
factories overseas
it'll raise billions of dollars
that's why i propose closing loopholes
for the very wealthy who don't pay
who pay a lower tax rate than a teacher
and a firefighter
so that's my plan but we have to go more
detail later
i'm going to grow we will grow the
economy
lower the cost of families
so what are we waiting for
let's get this done we all know we've
got to make changes
folks
and while you're at it
confirm my nominees for the federal
reserve
which plays a critical role
in fighting inflation
my plan will not only lower cost and
give families a fair shot
it will lower the deficit
the previous administration not only
ballooned the deficit with those tax
cuts for the very wealthy incorporations
it
undermined the watchdogs the job of
those to keep pandemic relief funds
being wasted remember we had those
debates
about whether or not those watchdogs
should be able to see every day how much
money was being spent where was it going
to the right place we did kind of my
administration
the watchdogs are
back we're going to go after the
criminals who stole billions of relief
money
meant for small business and millions of
americans tonight i'm announcing that
the justice department will soon name a
chief prosecutor from pandemic fraud
oh boy
look
they're gonna go after the ppp fraud
very strongly
i think we all agree thank you my
accountant said good thing you didn't
take that money david and half of what
it was before i took office
the only president ever to cut the
deficit by more than one trillion
dollars in a single year
lowering your cost also meant demanding
more competition
i'm a capitalist
but capitalism without competition is
not
capitalism
capitalism without competition is
exploitation
it drives up
profits not a joke
and corporations have to compete
their profits go up and your prices go
up when they don't have to compete
small businesses and family farmers and
ranchers i need not tell some of my
republican friends from those states
guess what
you got four basic meat packing
facilities
that's it
you play with them you don't get to play
at all
and you pay a hell of a lot more right a
hell of a lot more because only four see
what's happening with ocean carriers and
moving goods in and out of america
during the pandemic
about half a dozen or less foreign owned
companies raised prices by as much as
one thousand percent and made record
profits
tonight
i'm announcing a crackdown on those
companies overcharging american
businesses and consumers uh-oh
folks
you gotta explain that what does that
mean
is that price controls what is that
and as wall street firms take over more
nursing homes
quality in those homes has gone down i i
think we need a little more detail on
that don't we that ends on my watch
medicare is going to set higher
standards for nursing homes and make
sure your loved ones get the care they
deserve and that they inspect and they
will look that closely
we're also going to cut costs to keep
the economy going strong and giving
workers a fair shot
provide more training and
apprenticeships higher than based on
skills not just their degrees
let's pass the paycheck fairness act and
paid me
raise the minimum wage to 15 an hour
and extend the child tax credit so no
one has to raise the family in poverty
wow let's increase pell grants increase
our historic support for hbcus
and invest susan collins is really
disappointed with this full-time calls
america's best kept secret community
colleges
look
let's pass the pro act
when a majority of workers want a former
union they shouldn't be able to be
stopped
when we invest in our workers and we
build an economy from the bottom up in
the middle out together we can do
something we haven't done in a long time
build a better america for more than two
years covet has impacted every decision
in our lives
and the life of this nation
and i know you're tired frustrated and
exhausted
that doesn't even count
close to a million people
who sit at a dining room table or a
kitchen table and look at an empty chair
because they lost somebody
but i also know this
because of the progress we've made
because of your resilience
and the tools that we have been provided
by this congress
tonight i can say we're moving forward
safely
back to no no more normal routines
we've reached a new moment in the fight
against covet 19
where severe cases are down no level not
seen since july of last year
just a few days ago the center for
disease control and prevention
issued a new mass guidelines
under the new guidelines most americans
and most of the country
can now go mask free
and based on projections
and based on projections
more of the
country what's that point across the
next couple of weeks what a vile woman
the progress we made in the past year
covet 19 no longer need control our
lives
i know some are talking about living
with covet 19. but tonight i say
that we never will just accept living
with cover 19
we'll continue to combat the virus
as we do other diseases
and because this virus mutates and
spreads we have to stay on guard
and here are four common sense steps as
we move forward safely in my view here
we go first
stay protected with vaccines and
treatments
we know how incredibly effective
vaccines are
if you're vaccinated and boosted
you have the highest degree of
protection and we'll never give up on
vaccinating more americans
now i know parents with kids under five
are eager to see their vaccines
authorized for their children
scientists are working hard to get that
done we'll be ready with plenty of
vaccines if and when they do we're all
ready
we are also ready with anti-viral
treatments
if you get covered 19 the pfizer pill
reduces your chances of ending up in the
hospital by 90 percent
i've ordered more pills than anyone in
the world has
fizer is working overtime to get us a
million pills this month
and more than double that next month
and now we're launching the test to
treat
initiative so people can get tested at a
pharmacy and if they prove positive
receive the anti-viral pills on the spot
at no cost a good idea
folks that's big time
there's jerry nadler congressman
if you're immunocompromised or have some
other vulnerability
we have treatments
and free high quality masks we're
leaving no one behind or ignoring
anyone's needs as we move forward
on testing
we've made hundreds of millions of tests
available and you can order them for
free to your doorstep
and we've already ordered free tests if
you're already ordered free test tonight
i'm announcing you can order another
group of tests
go to coventtest.gov
i'm going to get some more next week and
you can get more tests yeah i'll get a
few more second
we must prepare for new variants
over the past we've gotten much better
at detecting new variants
if necessary we'll be able to develop
new vaccines within 100 days instead of
maybe months or years
and if congress provides the funds we
need we'll have new stockpiles of tests
mass pills ready if needed
i can't promise a new variant won't come
but i can't i can't promise you we'll do
everything within our power to be ready
if it does
third
we can end the shutdown of schools and
businesses
we have the tools we need
it's time for america to get back to
work and fill our great downtowns again
with people people working from home can
feel safe and begin to return to their
offices wow we're doing that here in the
federal government the vast majority of
federal workers
will once again work in person our
schools are open let's keep it that way
our kids need to be in school
with 75 percent of 75 of adult americans
fully vaccinated
and hospitalizations down by 77
most americans can remove their mass
and stay in the classroom and move
forward safely
we achieved this because we provided
free vaccines treatments tests and masks
of course continuing this costs money
so i'll not surprise you i'll be back to
see you all
and i'm going to soon send a request to
congress
the vast majority of americans have used
these tools and may want again
we may need them again so i expect
congress and i hope you'll pass that
quickly
fourth
we'll continue vaccinating the world
we've sent 475 million vaccine doses to
112 countries more than any nation on
earth
we won't stop
because you can't build a wall high
enough to keep out
a
a a a vaccine the vaccine can stop
the spread
of these diseases
you know we've lost so much in covert
19.
time with one another
the worst of all the much loss of life
let's use this moment to reset
so stop looking at covet as a partisan
dividing line
see it for what it is
a god-awful disease
let's stop sending each seeing each
other as enemies
and start seeing each other for who we
are
fellow americans
look
we can't change how divided we've been
there's a long time in coming
but we can change how to move forward
on covet 19 and other issues that we
must face together
i recently visited new york city police
department days after the funerals
officer
wilbur mora and his partner officer
jason rivera
they were responding to a 9 11 call when
a man shot and killed them with a stolen
gun
officer moore was 27 years old officer
vera was 22 years old
both dominican americans who grew up in
the same streets
that they later chose the parole to
patrol as police officers
i spoke with their families
and i told them they were forever in
debt for their sacrifices
and will carry on their mission to
restore the trust and safety in every
community deserves
like some of you that have been around
for a while
i've worked with you on these issues for
a long time
i know what works
investigating crime prevention and
community policing
cops who walk the beat
who know the neighborhood
and who can restore trust and safety
let's not abandon our streets
or choose between safety and equal
justice
let's come together and protect our
communities restore trust and hold law
enforcement accountable
that's why the justice department has
required
body cameras
banned choke calls and restricted no
knox warrants for its officers
that's why the american rescue plan
that you all provided 350 billion
dollars
that cities states and counties can use
to hire more police invest in more
proven strategies
proven strides like
proven strategies like community
violence interruption trusted messengers
breaking the cycle of violence and
trauma and giving young people some hope
we should all agree the answer is not to
defund the police is to fund the police
now republicans sort of sarcastically
cheering but remember
all almost no one is actually
trying to defund the police who's in
power you've got some municipality stuff
saying social workers okay it's kind of
a ruse protect our communities
i ask democrats and republicans alike
to pass my budget and keep our
neighborhoods safe
and we'll do everything in my power to
crack down on gun trafficking of ghost
guns that you can buy online
assemble at home
no serial numbers can't be traced
i ask congress to pass proven measures
to reduce gun violence
pass universal background checks why
should anybody not going to do it the
terrorist list be able to purchase a
weapon why
why they don't want to do universal
background checks the republicans don't
ban assault weapons with high capacity
magazines will open 100 rounds
do you think the deer wearing kevlar
vests
look repeal the liability shield that
makes gun manufacturers the only
industry in america that can't be sued
yep the only one that's a must
imagine had we done that with the
tobacco manufacturers
these laws don't infringe on the second
amendment they save lives it's bro bear
fundamental right in america is the
right to vote and have it counted
and look
it's under assault
in state after state new laws have been
passed
not only suppressed to vote we've been
there before but to subvert the entire
election
we can't let this happen
tonight i call on the senate to pass
pass the freedom to vote act pass the
john lewis act voting rights act
and while you're at it
pass the disclose act so americans know
who's funding our elections republicans
don't want people to vote that's how
they win by people not voting i like to
honor someone who dedicated his life to
serve this country
justice breyer
an army veteran
constitutional scholar
retiring justice of the united states
supreme court
justice breyer thank you for your
service
thank you thank you thank you
briar's a character isn't he guys
no matter what your ideology we all know
one of the most serious constitutional
responsibility a president has
is nominating someone to serve
on the united states supreme court
as i did four days ago right i've
nominated the circuit court of appeals
katangi brown jackson
one of our nation's top legal minds
will continue and just bribe justice
briar's
legacy of excellence
a former top litigator in private
practice
a former federal public defender
from a family of public school educators
and police officers
she's a consensus builder
since she's been nominated she's
received a broad range of support
including the fraternal order of police
and former judges supported by democrats
and republicans
folks
if we are to advance liberty and justice
we need to secure our border and fix the
immigration system
he's hitting a lot of important topics
but the transitions are very abrupt very
very abrupt
and as you might guess i think we can do
both
at our border
we've installed new technology like
cutting edge scanners to better detect
drug smuggling we've set up joint
patrols of mexico and guatemala to catch
more human traffickers
we're putting in place dedicated
immigration judges a significant larger
number so families fleeing persecution
and violence can have their curses casey
i'm guessing on twitter we'll be able to
see who yelled build the wall
we're screening we're securing
commitments and supporting partners in
south and central america to host more
refugees and secure their own borders
we can do all this while keeping lit the
torch of liberty that has led the
generation of immigrants to this land
my forebearers and many of yours
provide a pathway to citizens for
dreamers
those with temporary status that's a
must essential
revise our laws
so businesses have workers they need
and families don't wait decades to
reunite
it's not only the right thing to do it's
economically smart thing to do
that's why the immigration reform is
supported by everyone from labor unions
to religious leaders to the u.s chamber
of commerce
let's get it done once and for all
folks
advancing liberty and justice also
requires
protecting the rights of women
the constitution right affirmed by roe v
wade standing president for half a
century is under attack as never before
if you want to go forward not backwards
we must protect access to health care
preserve a woman's right to choose hey
guys for for people talking about
collins shaking her head i'm pretty sure
she has a condition some parkinsonian
type of thing i don't i don't think
she's shaking her head no for our lgbtq
plus americans
let's finally get the bipartisan
equality act to my desk
the onslaught of state laws targeting
transgender americans and their families
it's simply wrong
i said last year especially to our
younger transgender americans i'll
always have your back as your president
so you can be yourself and reach your
god-given potential
folks
as i've
just demonstrated all often appears we
do not agree
and that
we we do agree on a lot more things than
we acknowledge
i signed 80 bipartisan bills in the law
last year
from preventing government shutdowns
protecting asian americans from still
too common hate crimes to reforming
military justice
and will soon be strengthening the
violence against women act that i first
wrote three decades ago
it's important
a lot of them don't want that it's
important for us to show
to show the nation
we can come together and do big things
so tonight i'm offering a unity agenda
for the nation uh-oh four big things we
can do together in my view
first
beat the opioid
epidemic
there's so much
we can do
increased funding for prevention
treatment
harm reduction and recovery get rid of
outdated rules and stop doctors and and
the stats stop doctors from prescribing
treatments
stop the flow of illicit drugs by
working with state and local law
enforcement to go after the traffickers
and if you're suffering from addiction
you know you should know you're not
alone
i believe in recovery and i celebrate
the 23 million
23 million americans in recovery
second
let's take on mental health
especially among our children whose
lives and education have been
turned upside down
the american rescue plan gave schools
money to hire teachers and help students
make up for lost learning
i urge every parent to make sure your
school your school does just that they
have the money
we can all play a part
sign up to be a tutor or a mentor
children are also struggling before the
pandemic bullying violence trauma and
the harms of social media
as francis
haugen
who is here tonight with us
we must hold social media platforms
for the national experiment they're
conducting on our children for profit
folks
thank you
thank you for the courage you showed
it's time to strengthen privacy
protections
ban targeted advertising to children
demand tech companies stop collecting
personal data on our children
and let's get all americans the mental
health services they need
more people
can turn for help
and full parity between physical and
mental health care if we treat it that
way in our insurance
that's a must
look
at least everyone clapping for that
the third piece of that agenda
is support our
veterans
veterans are the backbone nancy pelosi
almost fell down
they're the best of us
i've always believed
that we have a sacred obligation to
cryptos we send to war
and care for those in their family when
they come home
my administration providing assistance
in job training housing and now helping
lower income veterans get va care debt
free
and our troops in iraq and faced in
afghanistan face many dangers
one being stationed at bases breathing
in toxic smoke from burn pits
many of you have been there what's nancy
pelosi doing out of iraq and afghanistan
over 40 times
anybody know what on earth nancy pelosi
is doing waste the waste of war
medical
and hazards material jet fuel and so
much more
and they come home
many of the world's fittest and
best-trained warriors in the world
never the same
headaches numbness dizziness
a cancer that would put them in a
flag-draped coffin
i know
who the hell just yells
one of those did you guys hear that son
major beau biden
i don't know for sure if the burn pit
who is yelling
hooch was near
in iraq and earlier than that in kosovo
is the cause of his brain cancer the
disease of so many other troops
but i am committed
to find out everything we can
committed
to military families like danielle
robinson from ohio
the widow of sergeant first class heath
robinson
he was born a soldier
army national guard
combat medic in kosovo in iraq
stationed near baghdad just yards from
burn pits the size of football fields
danielle is here with us tonight
they love going to ohio state football
games
who the hell yelled out when biden was
talking about his dead son it sounded
like marjorie taylor
and he greene building legos with their
daughter
but cancer from prolonged exposure to
burn pitch
ravaged heath's lungs and body
danielle says heath was a fighter to the
very end
he didn't know how to stop fighting
and neither did she
through her pain she found purpose
to demand that we do better
tonight danielle we are going to do
better
the va
the va is firing new ways of linking
toxic exposure to disease
already helping more
veterans get benefits and tonight
i'm announcing we're expanding
eligibility to veterans suffering from
nine respiratory cancers
i'm also calling on congress to pass a
law to make sure veterans devastated by
toxic exposure in iraq and afghanistan
finally get the benefits and the
comprehensive health care
and fourth and last
let's end cancer as we know it
this is personal
i'm being told green yelled out you put
13 of them in flag-draped coffins
and a kamala what a sick woman
so many of you have lost someone you
love
husband wife son daughter mom dad
cancer is the number two cause of death
in america second only to heart disease
last month
i announced the plan to supercharge the
cancer moonshot that president obama
asked me to lead six years ago
our goal is to cut cancer death rates by
at least 50 percent over the next 25
years i think we can do better than that
turn cancers
from death sentences into treatable
diseases
more support for patients and their
family now i'm being told it was lauren
bobert who yelled out not marjorie
taylor green what i called arpa h
advanced
advanced research
projects
agency for health
pattern after darpan the defense
department
projects that led in darpa to the
internet gps and so much more that make
our
forces more safer and be able to wage
war more with more clarity
arpa will have a singular purpose
to drive breakthroughs in cancer
alzheimer's and diabetes and more
a unity agenda for the nation
we can do these things it's within our
power
and i don't see a partisan edge to any
one of those four things
my fellow americans
tonight
we've gathered in this sacred space
a citadel of democracy
in this capital
generation after generational americans
have debated great questions
amid great strife
and i've done great things
we fought for freedom
expanded liberty
debated totalitarianism and terror
we built the strongest
freest and most prosperous nation the
world has ever known
now is the hour
our moment of responsibility
our test of resolve and conscience
of history itself
it is in this moment
that our character this generation is
formed
our purpose is found
our future is forged
well i know this nation
we'll meet the test
protect freedom and liberty
expand fairness and opportunity
and we will save democracy
as hard as those times have been i'm
more optimistic about america today than
i've been my whole life because i see
the future that's within our grasp
because i know there's simply nothing
beyond our
capacity
we're the only nation on earth that has
always turned every crisis we faced into
an opportunity
the only nation that can be defined by a
single word possibilities
so on this night
on our 245th year as a nation
i've come to report on the state of the
nation the state of the union and my
report is this
the state of the union is strong because
you the american people are strong
we are stronger today
we are stronger today than we were a
year ago
and we'll be stronger a year from now
than we are today
this is our moment
to meet and overcome the challenges of
our time and we will
as one people one america the united
states of america oh man god bless you
all
and may god protect our troops
thank you
this crowd
i guess at least republicans cheered for
ending cancer i mean i it's
so there is the state of the union
address from president joe biden
greeting any number of different people
here including senator amy klobuchar and
others
um i think my immediate reaction and you
guys tell me what you think and we've
got the republican response coming up
my immediate reaction is this was more
or less the tone that was expected
and that maybe makes sense given the
circumstances
almost everything that was proposed
will never see the light of day i mean
just
never see the light of day some of it
hopefully will
um and
it was uh an opportunity for republicans
to show their disdain
for just about anything joe biden wants
to do
uh regardless of whether
the legislative proposals will come
forward republicans are against it
they're against it that they made very
very clear
so that's my sense i mean i
i'm gonna think about it more overnight
before tomorrow's podcast but
i would give it
i think i would give it a b
i don't know
what do people think is
b plus seems too high but it wasn't bad
um
just kind of a b yeah i mean
i don't know
it was fine he did what did what he had
to do
uh
i mean i guess you know the
b minus a lot of people saying
yeah the transitions were notably bad
notably bad i i there was like a
whiplash sort of thing going on
um i the the transitions and i don't
think it was biden's fault i mean he was
just reading what was there
uh
very very strange very very strange but
you know certainly a solid b
um
i actually did not get bingo let me
think here he didn't whisper i didn't
see anybody sleeping no new expansion no
soul of america didn't say malarkey
didn't do i didn't he didn't call putin
a thug
didn't say my friends
didn't say that
oh he said make no mistake right i think
he did say here make no mis he did he
say here's the deal
hmm
i mean i guess with this i do have
diagonal bingo
make no mistake well listen he said a
bunch of the things i had on here it's
not it's about playing the game it's not
necessarily about about winning uh but
that's that's okay um please don't leave
by the way because we're about to hear
the republican response we're about to
hear the republican response which i'm
sure would be
horrifying absolutely horrifying thanks
to bernie on a boat for the twitch prime
subscription and just an absolutely
incredible day
uh oh thank thank you to red glowstick
as well
um jacob coming in with a 50 super chat
says don't know about a speech but i'll
give you an a pacman i appreciate that
i appreciate that
let's try to figure out
who actually yelled out
um let's see bober
yelled let's see if it's bobert
was it bobert
or was it green
it's not really clear to me
it was beaubert apparently
i'm seeing reports that it was that it
was indeed bobert guys super chats are
coming in as we wait for the republican
response i'm going to try to get to as
many as possible he didn't mention
student loans so he gets an f
b because so much of his agenda relies
on buildback better how are terrorists
like green and bobert even allowed in
the same room as the president that's a
good question
oust bober
and oust bober
here's justice stephen breyer who seemed
almost visibly bashful
when joe biden sung his praises
and breyer
seems to be
satisfied i guess what a character i
mean just his facial expressions are
amazing
uh what what a what an absolute
character
and off he goes i guess
joe biden speaking to
any number of different people
the republican response will be oh
people are saying don't even cover the
republican response
welcome even junior who's a new member
on my website
yeah all right you know what i'm i'm
fine let's do this instead since so many
people signed up let me just take a few
calls oh here's our friend um eric
swellwell i'm just going to take a few
calls instead of the republican response
i mean quite frankly i'm not going to
cover the republican response tomorrow
so it's kind of like who cares
i'd rather just hear from a few of you
guys
um if you want to talk to me go to
davidpakman.com
discord and get in the waiting lobby
and i will um
i'll talk to a few of you guys and and
but just do me one favor
please get right into your your comment
because otherwise it's going to get very
very ugly davidpakman.com
discord get in the waiting lobby and go
right into your comment we'll hear from
a few people if you're heading out uh
make sure you're following us on
whatever platform you know youtube or
twitch or whatever but let's let's hear
from a few people here just to see
what's on people's minds first on the
air is john from san francisco john
what'd you think
hey can you hear me david yes i can john
great great um
thank you for doing these i really
appreciate your uh your input on these
that's all i wanted to say oh thank you
so much i appreciate that
you're welcome everything good in san
francisco
as good as it can be everything uh
opening back up so glad to see that all
right very good i appreciate the call
thank you all right john from san
francisco checking in
let's go rapid fire next to adam from
mississippi what'd you think adam
i i uh liked it i thought he did a
pretty good job
what'd you think was the weakest moment
and b i think b okay
but i wanted to ask you will there be
any is there any sort of like rule set
up against someone shouting out in the
way that
supposedly bobert did i think it's just
a decorum thing i think it's just she's
vile you know i don't think it's about
rules um
there may be you know kind of like there
they may put out a thing saying you did
a bad like they did to that guy i think
it was joe wilson who yelled out when
obama was speaking but i don't know that
there's a rule per se
okay i mean maybe she was out of maybe
she was out of order we might say i
don't know
i mean i agree like yeah absolutely out
of order totally vile but i was hoping
there was some sort of uh
uh
tangible repercussion she might be able
to face but if not
you know i suppose it is what it is i
wouldn't hold my breath yeah all right
thank you all right thank you
uh people are actually doing a good job
today of getting right into their their
question or comment let's go next to
miles from michigan miles from michigan
you're on the air what's going
on i thought that was a pretty good
speech and everything but much of the
last caller yeah i just honestly was
disgusted by whoever it was yelling out
just like come on i'm being told it was
bobert yeah it was totally disgusting
yeah so i mean just a horrible person
you know
yeah
there's people like for example there's
people who aren't my thing politically
but like i i i i'm only mentioning mitt
romney just because i've seen you know
documentaries about him and know people
that know him i'm not with mitt romney
politically but i would be sort of
generally interested in sitting down
with mitt romney and having a
conversation i have it just i have no
interest in ever being around bober or
saying a word to her she's just gross
you know rob i definitely can second
what you're saying about romney because
yeah romney has shown
time and time again you know sure he's a
republican but at the same time he
doesn't let that force
go being a good human being yeah yeah to
some degree at least anyway i mean
strapping the dog to the roof of his car
while it had diarrhea wasn't exactly the
most great thing to do but you know i
think he learned from that i'm sorry did
i miss something yeah romney did that
that was a big thing he strapped his dog
to the roof of his car and it was so
anxious it was it was having explosive
diarrhea during an entire road trip
okay well um that's the thing
all right miles from michigan thank you
are you in that upper peninsula piece
that's like separated by a lake
no you're not okay
all right thank you for the call my
friend
yep thank you all right let's go
next to
laurie from is it laurie from mexico
yep cute all right
let's go
next to
laurie from is it briefly
oh [ __ ]
let's go next to
lori
uh moving on um let's go next
let's go next to kenzie from houston
kenzie what did you think of the speech
moving on um let's go next time
from houston kenzie what did you think
hi david uh i'm actually a history
teacher so i was uh kind of critiquing
it the entire time
okay and what were your critiques and
please
kenzie you got to turn that off you got
to talk to personally i would give them
like a b or so um but really my question
is
how do you think like what do you think
joe manchin
needs to convince him to vote for
biden's agenda well it depends on which
bill you're talking about i don't think
there's just one thing
but you know man i think mansion needs
goodies as we like to call them um i
don't know i don't know what's going on
with mansion but i think we just got to
flip some seats i don't think we can
even need to be counting on mansion
okay
thank you kenzie
very very chaotic phone call
extraordinarily chaotic phone call it
was going so well but then it got
really really tough
let's go to mike from queens new york
mike what did you think
hey david thank you for the stream
please i just wanted to make a comment
that we've had obama who was heckled yep
trump who to my knowledge was not
heckled
by then who was hacked yep so is this
just something we have to accept that
when a democrat holds the state of the
union they're going to get heckled
basically and and they'll be called the
communists too you know obama was called
a communist and biden's called the
communists so yeah it's uh it's just it
is i guess this is what what it is now
yeah i find the double standard it's a
little bit frustrating but
you know i guess it is what it is and
yeah that's all i had to say how's
queens these days
it's fine you know there's some
corruption with eric adams and
everything so people aren't too happy
about that but all the mandates here are
lifting new york city's going back to
normal so
you know it's i mean it's kind of been
business as usual for a while nobody's
really been wearing the mask as far as i
can tell stores still have the signs up
please wear a mask but you go in there
and nobody's enforcing it nobody's
wearing it you ever go to the uh
argentinian restaurants in queens
there's some good ones
i haven't been to like a real restaurant
since before the pandemic really i mean
i do like little take out from local
places i've been mostly trying to stay
away from it got it got it and you don't
go to chick-fil-a do you
uh the chick-fil-a there is they are
opening more chick-fil-a's it used to be
a struggle to find one but no i've never
been to a chick-fil-a once beautiful all
right i congratulate you thank you for
the call
thank you very much all right guys by
the way if you want to talk to me you
got to get in the waiting lobby on our
discord all of these people
trying to call me and sending me direct
messages on discord i'm just going to
have to ban you a block you because it's
just too annoying you know i gotta i
have a system here guys i have a system
let's go to paul garcia from mexico go
paul garcia from mexico
go
hmm
all right well
that's too bad
let's go next to william from las vegas
william you are on the air what's going
on what'd you think
david uh great to talk to you again um
now hold on a second william are you the
financial advisor with the trumpest
clients from vegas
negative sir negative
no good sir no i uh i'm the guy that you
recommended vesta roastery coffee uh to
a long time ago oh okay very good
which is a great coffee place tremendous
coffee tremendous coffee yes
um i agree that there probably won't be
a whole lot of policy that sees the
light of day
but let's talk about how refreshing it
was to have a state of the union where
president at least brought up policy
sure he talked about bridges that's true
yeah it's like there's levels right
trump doesn't even mention policy biden
does but none of it will pass it is
better i do i agree with you at least
there's like the idea of what you might
do if you didn't have obstructionist
republicans ruining everything you tried
to do that's right so at least on that
on that aspect i'd say
b plus maybe a minus that were that
we're getting back more closer to normal
yeah i mean even a lot of the policy he
mentioned he was like we're gonna
crack down on people charging customers
too much it's like dude what are you
talking about are you talking about
price controls like what was that even
about
at least it's not name calling like uh
like what we had with uh brandex before
i agree
i agree i'm happy i'm with you i'm with
you
thank you so much i appreciate it hey
listen question for you i might go to
vegas in a month but i'm not sure just
because like is it is it insane there
right now like what's going on is it
just gonna feel crazy after two years of
a pandemic to go to vegas in a month
well when was the last you haven't been
here for two years yeah
okay so it is a little bit different
because we're so close to california and
there was this big exodus from
california uh because uh people were
frustrated with the max the mass
mandates in california even though we
still had them here uh the casinos were
pretty locked down on the mass mandates
because that's where their money comes
from they didn't want to have an
outbreak to kind of lock down the
casinos right but right now on the strip
or fremont uh it's pretty wide open and
also depends on what you do i mean i
don't know what you have planned to do
here um but but it's i mean it's it's
not crazy
and bear in mind i'm talking about las
vegas crazy it's normal for vegas okay
yeah no i'd be going to like a small
conference and just having some dinners
and meetings and stuff like that
oh you should be fine uh sadly there was
a this horrible uh instance where our
government was accosted uh just the
other night here as him and his family
were eating dinner uh i'll send you the
the clip or the news link on twitter it
was pretty gross but
by and large if you're coming here i
think you'll be fine with it um
hopefully you will all right i'll wear a
hazmat suit just in case
well if i see a coffee's on me this time
all right thank you there's william from
vegas checking in with us very very
strongly we're taking calls via discord
davidpakman.com discord let's go next to
steph from glasgow steph it's gotta be
what 3 30 in the morning there what are
you doing
steph from glasgow you're on the air
steph
session of the two houses
now can you hear me yes i can steph are
you in glasgow scotland
i am yeah and is it 3 30 in the morning
uh yes yes and what are you doing
calling me right now
well
i stayed up specifically to watch the
stream oh my god thank you i think
you're like the all-star caller of the
day
oh brilliant
yeah i just wanted to say thank you for
streaming because i wouldn't have
watched it otherwise so thank you now
i'm curious
do you care about the president of the
us giving a state of the union
um
you know
i think see because of the like the
previous president for the last four
years and the
the laughingstock that he made of
america i think it's just like
refreshing to see somebody that seems
like they actually care you're reveling
in the normality of it it sounds like
yeah i mean
biden compared to our boris johnson as
refreshing also so yes that's true hey
listen when you hear me speak with my
southwestern new england accent does it
sound strange to you where you go whoa
that's a weird way to speak english
uh yeah the way that you say some things
um
i don't know just it sounds weird to me
that's fascinating like what's what's a
particular word that i say weird
um oh recently um how do you say moscow
moscow
yeah because you i think you you see
no i say i say moscow moscow is how i
think i say it moscow and i i say moscow
moscow
yeah
okay is there any other one
not that i can think of off the top of
my head more that's that's stunning uh
all right well wow do you have to get up
early tomorrow for work or something
um
no actually i'm i'm not working at the
moment but um i think i'm also just up
late because i'm quite anxious because
we're getting some scan results for my
mum tomorrow so sorry you're what you're
getting scammers out tomorrow did you
say
scan results oh scan results oh all
right well i wish you absolutely the
best with that i hope it's all positive
i hope it's negative
what i mean is i hope everything's fine
you know what i'm saying yeah
yeah i appreciate that as it's my mom um
and it might it's probably going to be
cancer so i'm really sorry to hear that
thank you thank you
i appreciate you calling in
no worries thanks for taking my call
okay stay stay in touch wow stuff from
glasgow that's tough
that's very very tough
uh
really really appreciate speaking with
steph though
let's see who else we can talk to here
i don't know maybe jess from florida
jess
from florida
hello
hey jess yes i can
hey so um i missed the beginning of the
state of the union but um
basically i
i wish she went over more detail like
fewer points in more detail i know and
honestly
this guy knows like he knows how to tell
a speech and i wish
he brought like the crowd together more
at the end maybe bringing up ukraine at
the end
for optics like it would have gotten
both sides excited you know what i mean
yeah i agree with you i think like
that's why i said it's a b
i think the order of the speech could
have been better i think the pacing
could have been better
and i think maybe touching on a few
fewer topics in slightly more detail i
would have preferred but who the hell am
i you know
i would i would say maybe c plus b minus
a little nice on him yeah oh and one
more thing real quick
um i'm like i don't know i think that
bringing up whoever was like
chanting or like trying to
trying to make little nasty comments
during his speech i don't think it's
worth living and giving them that much
attention you know that's fair that's
fair yeah no you you may be right they
what they're desperate for attention
jess where in florida are you
gainesville i'm uh i'm actually the one
who called uh last week oh okay you know
i got a bunch of complaints from people
in gainesville who said
the person told you gainesville's
conservative but it's actually liberal
and i looked it up and it is
it's true it's true so we're like a
little tiny blue oasis like a little
blue dot in a sea of red right
uh
but also i mean okay
i i gotta also say
much love to my floridian friends yes
but
we are not nearly as liberal as
games billions think like i have family
in oregon i have family in california
uh and even in phoenix like
we're
we're purple we're purple okay
can you get a good bagel in that part of
florida or is it too far from where the
jews are
it's a little bit too far
a bit too swampy out here that's what i
thought that's what i thought in miami
you can get great bagels jess thank you
for the call i appreciate it
thank you for letting me speak all right
jess from florida clarifying
misstatements from before
let's go to alozec from the united
kingdom what is are you also up late
alozec
alozek hello
hello david yes
um i was going to give the speech a
c but then the reaction that i got from
watching
um the audio from overlapping in the
disco calls made it give me about an a
maybe a minus in other words the speech
was a c but the infinite audio loop from
the person listening
incorrectly on discord made you rate the
stream itself much higher
um i would say so yes but um even if
that has nothing to do with the speech
itself i would say that made it a lot
more enjoyable i understand well i
appreciate that
many thanks to you uh well
um
i will catch you later well and let me
ask why why are you up in the middle of
the night
um because i just play video games oh
and how late how late do you stay up
gaming
because it's like three or four ish
it's not usually three or four it's just
up but um this is a rarity for me and
then when do you wake up if you go to
bed at four
oh
typically would be
one-ish
1pm
yeah oh my goodness wow wow what a
schedule
yeah okay all right well thank you for
the call
and thank you for the stream all right
wow there we go
incredible callers i'm learning so much
let's go to casey from denver casey
you're on the air
hey david how are you i'm doing well
yeah i think um i would give that uh
state of the union a very powerful b
okay not a b plus not a b minus but a
powerful b yeah i think it was a b it
was like b minus starts to seem
too low and it certainly wasn't a b plus
that's how i end up on a b
yeah um
yeah i enjoyed just sort of the uh the
camera kind of cutting to
uh different political figures faces
like i think it was you know talking
about uh women's uh you know right to
choose and they cut over to amy coney
barrett and
it's always interesting to see those
reactions it is i agree with you
all right well appreciate the stream all
right thank you there is denver colorado
checking in let's go to
shayna from california shayna you're on
the air what'd you think of the speech
david sir i give the speech at a minus
to a b plus wow ma'am that's quite high
and well because you have says little
missteps like iranian yeah
but
i know the maggots are gonna jump down
his throat over that but
you all know what he meant to say he
didn't it's not like you see it on
purpose what was your um what was your
favorite policy proposal that he made
oh
the ban on ghost guns and universal
background checks okay that's fair
that's fair yeah i mean it would be
great to get that done i don't think
there's any chance but
but he was very convincing though good
well i'm glad i'm glad you liked it
everybody's entitled to their opinion
you thought it was slightly better than
i thought and that's fine
especially the the conclusion
i mean the conclusion is more powerful
than anything else that was the highest
energy that was the highest energy
moment that's his high point go get him
beautiful all right well shayna thank
you
okay
all right shayna with probably the
highest ratings so far
uh let's try becca from lancaster becca
you're on the air what did you think
um hi
i really liked it i liked what he had to
say about schools
um
and the importance of kids being in
schools i work in a school um so
um that really
that really stood out to me
interesting and uh are you you are you i
don't know is the school you're in has
it gone mask-free yet
it is mask-free i still wear mine my
daughter wears her oh okay
yeah but i'm a lunch lady and
what what i really appreciated last year
and this year is that meals are free for
all students
and next school year that's not going to
be the case anymore and i really wish
that that is something that would be
extended because so many families
benefit from that this has been talked
about and you know fox news was like
what you know imagine if kids grow up
thinking lunch is free it's like oh my
god that's the reason not to do it kids
might grow up thinking lunch is free i
absolutely think uh school lunch should
be free uh you know the reduced and the
free tickets have a different color
typically it stigmatizes the kids who
are getting the reducer free lunch it's
it's all bad now i you know we all have
memories from lunch ladies growing up
can you give us sort of like a
what's the secret that lunch ladies hold
that would be shocking to everybody who
has ever
been in a school like what what do we
not know about what's happening behind
the scenes with lunch ladies
oh my goodness we can have fun we have
dance parties we play the music loud
we we have fun wow so when we go down
there and the lunch ladies seem
miserable and they're handing out the
sandwiches
behind earlier they were actually
enjoying themselves
yes absolutely that makes me feel a
little bit better i have to tell you
yes yes
all right good thank you so much for the
call yeah thanks for taking my call all
right becca from lancaster county
very very strong
um let's go next to jamie on oahu what
time is it in hawaii is it like 5 40 p.m
or something
exactly 5 40 p.m wow
thank you for the call what what's on
your mind
i'm just um i'm a little disappointed
that nothing's moving with our current
administration yeah unhappy with the
prices over here okay and hawaii i mean
prices are outrageous in hawaii because
it's an island right
yes yes our gas prices are outrageous
milk is outrageous luckily i don't drink
milk so that doesn't really affect me
but obviously gas does i live off grid
so
what's gas going for in hawaii
about 4
40 a gallon for 87.
yep oh that seems high yep that seems
high
what's a gallon of milk
a gallon of milk's about seven bucks
really now is that like uh pasture
raised organic or what
that's just regular milk oh my god is it
is it at least it's a gallon though for
sure
yeah
wow yeah if you got cashed or raised
organic you'd be looking at like nine
dollars
the eggs are really expensive too you
know so
unless you get like mainland eggs and
those are not you want to get like local
eggs because you want to support the
local farmers of course so
do you find that people's behavior is
act because that's a place where there's
just it's always expensive and why are
people modifying their behavior because
of the prices
i think so yeah because i think that
people are trying to buy local to
support each other yeah you know like
they're trying to buy more of the local
produce
which is more expensive because it's
just really expensive like farm eating
is expensive in itself right it's crazy
though because you would think what's
expensive is flying things out there but
you're saying even the local stuff is
very expensive
well yeah because it just it's hard it's
hard work you know yes
but
the
um
farming
wide scale
by definition makes it cheaper for them
you know so they are able to undercut
the small
you know the boutique farmers gotcha
gotcha
yeah
and is it 88 degrees
all year every day
it gets a little cooler at night if that
makes you feel better what is it 80 at
night or
um i live up on a mountain so it drops
down to like 60 at night oh okay but
it's 88 during the day i have to use a
blanket i have to put it i have to put a
hoodie on okay so well listen it sounds
like the struggle is real so i'm gonna
yeah
i'll let you get back to that struggle
all right all right okay thank you jamie
from hawaii
very very interesting callers here
um why don't we check in with timothy
from miami timothy is are you calling
from miami or miami beach
oh god why don't we check in with
timothy from miami timothy is are you
calling from miami or miami beach uh
miami okay timothy could you listen to
me and discord instead of through the
stream because otherwise we'll have a 15
second delay hello yeah
david can you hear me
yes i
can hello
hi
oh uh man i can't believe i'm here
i can't either
okay um
yeah so the thing is um
sorry about the noise i just didn't
expect it but um the thing about the
state of the union is i thought it was
very good i mean the thing about biden
is
you know he's a very interesting type of
speaker but you know
thing is i also wanted to ask you a
question of are you covering the
republican response tonight no uh it's
on right now i mean we're watching it
and if people want to read the subtitles
they can but i'm talking to you instead
you feeling like that was the right
decision
oh okay cool
all right then david that's pretty much
it thank you
all right thank you i actually don't
know that i think the entire call he
might have been listening to his
speakers i don't know
i don't know that we i think it only by
chance sort of seemed like a
conversation
um but you guys let me know let's go
next to haley from georgia hayley what's
going on
hey david good to talk to you again
likewise
um i just wanted to
ask you if
uh
was mitch mcconnell's face enough to put
sleeping republicans on my bingo
card um
you know technically he did seem awake
he seemed comatose or sedated but i do
think technically he was awake
yeah right i mean i think i think we
would be taking a liberty if we checked
off
audience members sleeping just on the
basis of him being
he was as still as i've ever seen a
human being be but i agree um i also
just wanted to thank you um for
featuring me in the mailbag a couple
weeks ago and last week he featured me
on pacman live and our last call and
that was just so great oh and what what
was your email that got featured
uh it was the uh the
the one on the carhart
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah you wrote in
something about how it was cracking you
up that
the the republicans are burning carhartt
stuff because they're pissed about the
vaccines but then a lot of the stuff's
flame retardant right
yes and i was like it's like making my
day and i was like does that make me a
bad person and then today you said
something about like does like something
make me a bad person for
appreciating them being so mad oh yeah
no the the trucker convoy the fact that
it failed so hard it just brings me joy
i don't know
[Laughter]
all right well haley thank you great uh
great to check in
yes good to talk to you all right take
care there's haley from
georgia let's go to gage from delaware
gage did delaware's own joe biden make
you proud tonight
well kind of sorta yeah uh relative to
like obama and trump like he's kind of
in the middle yeah when it came to
giving speeches i feel like honestly he
really deserved like a c
okay you call you would you so you don't
agree with me on b you think it was a c
speech
yeah i mean for joe biden's standards i
definitely think it's a b but it's
probably more of a c if we had to be you
know kind about it
you mean if we weren't on a curve you're
saying it would be a c yeah if we
weren't doing the bell curve yeah
no i know i mean
it's just like
i don't know my i expectations are
pretty low it's just sort of like given
the state of the world and the state of
politics how good is the speech really
going to be you know i i do get what
you're saying
yeah i mean
the substance was pretty all right but
like you said i don't think most of
things are going to really be foreseen
they're going to be done
yeah the order was weird the transitions
were bizarre i think you should have
maybe ended with some ukraine stuff and
then like actually explained how we
would even accomplish one of the things
he mentioned yeah there's a lot of
things to criticize maybe it was a
b-minus i don't know now i'm talking
myself into a b-minus
okay yeah i would agree with that more
yeah but i also have one quick question
please so um i actually shop at this um
mission like mennonite store okay and
they have like a lot of like
misinformation about kevin 19 and
everything like that
and like i kind of take some of the
pamphlets that like openly
play that master killing people and
stuff would you say that's like uh
something you agree with or disagree
with i disagree that masks are killing
people
okay well now i meant like no i'm
kidding you're saying do i agree with
taking all their pamphlets right i i'm
not and i'm not saying they're the ones
that put a male i think someone else
like it's like a public space i think
that that's basically a victimless crime
i think taking all the pamphlets instead
of one so that there aren't any left i
can get behind that i think that that's
good you're not doxing anybody you're
not hurting anybody i i think that's
fine people in the audience can agree or
disagree but yeah i can't tell you that
what you're doing is morally wrong
okay well i just always wanted that
opinion i appreciate it now you are
recycling them right
oh yeah okay if you were taking them and
thr
if you were taking them and throwing
them in the trash i would have to tell
you it's not okay but it's like as long
as you're recycling them it's good
yeah i have a small stash underneath my
call my car seat matt beautiful
yeah beautiful beautiful yeah all right
gage keep up the good work thank you man
sometimes i crack myself up i really do
uh let's see who else we can talk to
here um
it's tough because there's just so many
people
who are
i did not expect a call about amish
pamphlets anti-vaxx anti-mask pamphlets
that's for sure
why don't we talk to
annabelle annabelle
go
um hi
i
was just thinking about uh putin and why
he
did this now like why not do it when he
was when um
trump was president because
yeah trump was putin and would probably
help yeah i mean i think um i i think
there's it's very hard to explain the
behavior of such a chaotic narcissist
it's sort of like why did trump do any
of the things he did when he did them
it's it's a similar thing like why did
trump take classified documents rather
than declassify them or or whatever
i don't really think we're going to know
the answer republicans will say putin
didn't do it under trump because he was
scared of trump and i think of course
there's no evidence of that i think that
another interpretation that's
speculative would be well putin didn't
do it under trump because he felt like
he didn't need to because things were as
good as they had been for a while under
trump i just don't think we have the
answer i don't know that it's useful to
speculate because putin's a chaotic guy
i just don't think we know right now
yeah you know all right well that was
about it
all right well thank you for the call
annabelle
yep see you later see you later
all right everybody thank you that is
gonna do it we have seen the state of
the union we were all here we brought in
close to 200 memberships
and it's been quite an evening it really
has been i appreciate everybody who
joined me
and um it's 4am where i am so i've got
to get to bed
i will see everybody
very very soon that's a joke
sort of
maybe
but not really see you soon